all right and we are both live the last
word with kognito and it bounces what's
going on well it's been a crazy week
destiny feels like smashing everything
in a one week every time so I've been
like up at odd hours playing crazy stuff
trying to do a new quest and a bunch of
other stuff and then I'm literally going
through a checklist last night on the
stream like okay so I've got a reverie I
need to go work on this and then I need
to go do shadow throwing but did you
shout out there and flawless and after
that aydin's you have you have you and
it's just like oh my god on Sunday and
everything else is just like yeah
we got so much going on right you took
what human I know you really you've been
burning a candle man you've been laying
in the field on either this weekend like
sign name just gonna be like all what in
the football game just sitting there
like cinema like game time is just gonna
be sleeping commercial okay
trust me Oh which you bet I've heard too
there's been a very very busy week but
uh it was sneaking a little bit of
gaming with so you know starts at least
start my last word quests you know at
least you got the hotness already so I'm
a little jealous
that's alright you actually have to be
good with it for it to be hotness you're
not there yet no no no definitely need
some work to be put in on that gun but
overall like you know I know what get
into it stuff later but um like you feel
you feel good about it
overall like how always I was presented
know the quest of a gun the quest
yeah the quest isn't bad definitely
teasing some things so but overall yeah
not bad definitely there's some I mean
well yes you said we'll get into the
nitty-gritty of the quest itself but
yeah I kind of like um you know there's
a cool mechanic in the end which I
probably will try not to spoil you know
we've just got a couple other things to
it but I mean overall it you know it's
nice that it wasn't time gated yes yes
that's probably be a well the biggest
one so you can just work through it at
your timing you're not like hey I got so
this step up I gotta wait a week two
weeks yeah and third week finally got my
Thunder Lord so like they didn't do that
again so
at least hats off to that part
absolutely absolutely I definitely love
that part you can just jump right in not
a lot of people were pleased with
certain steps but we'll talk about that
later right
but overall Beca I got like a lot to get
done I want to get that finished up you
know playing a lot of crucible you know
as part of it and then um just trying to
get other stuff done in prep of all
these games we got going on you know
especially this weekend big weekend
going on with other games - oh yeah he's
like this uh it's why the big old image
has got destiny and a giant slash and
then and oh yeah hey hit them baby
oh yeah so second part of this podcast
is gonna be a pretty heavy on anthem we
will try and touch a little bit on
division two just because the payment
details are coming the week after so
we've got like demo demo beta know life
but yeah so we got a week and a half of
Destiny to catch up on then we'll jump
into the beta yes or the demo whatever
you want to call it then we'll jump into
the other beta so lots of stuff to talk
about this morning with you guys so
welcome everybody and as you guys tune
in live on twitch.tv slash e bone tests
or iron Lords podcast on YouTube we do
this live every Friday morning 8 a.m. so
if you're catching the archive later on
then welcome to the party
absolutely but as you guys have seen on
the images here we've been working with
you know a new name we worked on that
first oh I nearly got killed by my
podcast go home he was almost assaulted
we got through it together there were
some questions things have been all
worked out I was just like I was like to
be sure I'm very picky so we went
through that but there was there was a
lot less question on the second part so
thanks you Cognito honest and shout out
to mr. graphic God in chats Jay we have
a new image for the podcast so we're
gonna go ahead and drop the bomb right
now pretty early on if you guys are if
you guys ever catch this later on on
audio go look this one up this is where
it got put out their lives so this is
the new logo shout out to graphic god he
put it all together and before I show it
we wanted something that represented
basically what we do so kognito has his
icon of the ninja
you guys we've seen that one and I'm the
cheetah so both of us like how do you
put how do you put that in an image but
basically it's just you know II bought
the Sun kognito we sit around and chat
and hang out with you guys and we just
cover as much as we can a lot about
destiny but looter shooters are growing
so we'll add a couple two to the mix
here and there and we wanted something
that represented all that and honestly
like there were a couple sketches that
brought it together and then graphic God
just sends over like the first render
and we're like we're done we're good I
mean it was we're like I don't know it's
like I'm not sure and then BAM there it
is so it was awesome so here it is in
three two one
there it is so honestly like it looks so
good because it's I mean we just we were
talking about this before we got on
because you've got both of us sitting
around a fire so it's just this like you
know kind of normal neutral just like
sitting around a campfire type Chad and
then it's in the forest and you've got
to set it's two things that would never
be sitting next to each other it's just
a representation of us like the cheetah
and the ninja sitting there chilling
having a chat and like the speak bubbles
shout out to grafica that you put on the
text here I was like that's perfect
nothing it doesn't have the microphone
in there but it's a way to say that
there's like there's talking involved
and I was like oh it was so good let me
jump into because yeah sorry I'm
literally like picking my brain like the
thing is it's like what I like you said
is that there's two characters that
represent us that technically like you
said you shouldn't have anything in
common
but it's like that spiritual connection
you don't say that you got like the
little campfire a chat you know they're
going on so for me I also get like the
mental telepathy vibe we're always kind
of thinking about the same thing you
know I'm saying and also as an
old-school I'm showing my age right now
but as an old-school game I don't know
if you I remember that game shadow
dancer and it's basically from the
shinobi series and like the ninja had
like this animal you know saying like it
was a spiritual connection between both
so shout out to the gravit gosh how did
jade uh you know saying like i know we
was probably difficult to deal with miss
big down but y'all he nailed he went
from like
you know five to ten mile an hour to a
poem 100-mile now's the time we like wow
you got it man so shout out to him
the last word shadowblade xru I like it
thank you sir
yeah man that's what we running with and
yeah we definitely think it represents
us you know I'm saying again just to two
friends common thought process you know
fireside chat and we're gonna be talking
about all these Luna shooters and these
games deep in the wilderness secret
about this meeting we can't tell
everybody where it's at snags like a
secret location you know that that that
spiritual connection between is fire me
I love it
he nailed it man fantastic Jack could
not recommend j-dub enough man you are
the man yeah so thank you sir the work
is awesome
I wish I had a creative bone in my body
I don't I was like I was really obvious
I was working on the thumbnail for
anthem and and I was like I posted
something up or whatever and there was a
guy in that in the discord that I was in
for an anthem and and he sent me a DM
real quick and we started chatting up
and I was like he's like yeah just give
her a Photoshop for fun and just like
the quick tweaks he had I was like oh
this looks like 10,000 times better from
my like Jay I was like thank you so I
was like I I could use all the help I
can get so somehow you guys have found
me through my terrible thumbnails as it
is so I appreciate you guys looking past
those and enjoying the contents because
the art bones are not in my body so it's
not the most excites reading good yo J
he said that's how fire literally large
for how close we are to it I may be
changing the hair on my tummy right
there you're protected by your ninja
Apparel's but my cheetah may be losing
some hair actually I'm not sure but it's
the metaphorical campfire but no I was
like it's it's awesome so I just yeah I
just like I just sit there and look at
it's like the trees in the background a
little bit it's just like I don't know
you crushed it man so hats off and thank
you and when we work on now we finally
got a logo so I can work on putting this
thing on a audio platform so stay tuned
guys once that is official I will be
calm down graphic god
yeah so I will be working on getting the
audio stuff because I had a lot of
people request but they're like can't
like drain my phone battery and stuff
like that so now that we've got the logo
and I can actually put this on there
well definitely I'm gonna work on
getting this up so I don't know how far
back I'm gonna go archive wise I may
work on that stuff later but for now I'm
gonna work on at least the newer ones so
you can get those going to you guys on
audio so stay tuned for announcement
when that stuff is actually an audio
form as well yes sir but it has been a
crazy week and esta new things have
happened lots of things have happened
speaking of firsts let's get to it
a patch yes we have so last week we
didn't do for one way the anthem VIP
demo we were waiting on the table to
come out and there at least it like
later on Friday and it wasn't even that
much so I know you guys may have missed
us last week but thank you guys for
being patient we are back and we got
just a tease basically that we knew
mayhem was coming which you know we'll
talk about as we've been playing through
we've got Crimson Day is coming in a
couple weeks which there's a little bit
on that but it seems just I kind of
figured it wouldn't be that much and you
know we kind of know it is and then they
talked a little bit about a tease of
what's coming up we have full patch
notes now and oh my gosh there's a lot
to cover here so I a lot of changes in
supers probably more than I've seen ever
maybe I don't know it's it's up there
for sure who I was talking to but um I
think the argument was made that it
probably just as much as uh as Forsaken
if not more you know me so yeah there's
a lot of changes we got a deep dive into
Mannie and get to it now that we've been
in this new super tuned meta let's get
it alright so they just jump straight
into it with super tuning and we're
going to go a hunter gunslinger first
and if you guys have not been in mayhem
and you should go in there for a little
while not specifically for this but this
is definitely one of the things in this
the Golden Gun super so first thing
increase the damage to bosses by 40% and
that includes both the six-shooter
and celestial nighthawk that's insane
that thing already does a ton of damage
yes
did you see the clips of what people are
doing to Calais oh I think I didn't they
like I don't even know if it got to the
sniper did they just one shot him with
Golden Gun it was insane
yeah like one second kill or something
yeah literally like they shot him up and
then literally he's throwing up his hand
for the last phase with no edits I'm
like yeah it was like the game didn't
even know how to handle it it was funny
I'm done
yes yes yeah Forte said it once I could
kill ya it's crazy right now
Goldin done right now a shout-out to a
read it real quick because somebody
already said if they already did this
before Kate would still be alive oh my
god if you had the Golden Gun / yes
we'll get that one what's up traumatic
how you doing so the next one is the
Golden Gun six-shooter this is a change
that in the right hands is quite lethal
so the base damage increase from 275 to
300 per shot and I'm guessing that's
like PvP damage I think yeah but this
this is the big one
and I did not see this coming and then
they had the little preview video out
and everybody's like scratching their
head and they're like are you are you
serious
kills now return a bullet two golden
guns magazine Wow
that's game-changing that's just like
Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam Lego just
keep lighting them up listen hunt is I
don't want to hear it right now how to
know you guys got nothing to talk about
we're gonna get mayhem in a little bit
oh my gosh that right there is so huge
like just that continuous it is a terror
in the crucible - I'm like you you fear
gunslingers now because they you know if
you get picked off that soup is gonna
extend and it's man it's even more like
uh yeah powerful powerful yeah so have
you have you seen the Goldie's coming at
you in the
we gonna talk about cruise will later
after we get through everything we want
talking I got to see what a screen was
movie it was that I had a lot to say
alright so next we've got lining them up
double precision damage bonus per stack
of the buff I don't even remember what
line them up does I should have actually
looked isn't that like see so precision
hits with Golden Gun increase its damage
and extended straighten Oh double
precision damage bonus first her stack
holy crap that's it double precision
bonus damage yeah so yeah I mean Golden
Gun on the other side too if you start
hitting because I think that's the free
shot not the sick shot right yeah so I
mean if you get three precision shots
double double down so yeah I mean
they're definitely giving Golden Gun a
massive boost in PvE which is good
honestly because it needed it in that
now I mean it sounds like it's maybe a
little broken but I mean they're
definitely making the game a lot more
fun with a lot of stuff they've been
doing lately so definitely that is kind
of insane press that practice makes
perfect
that's the one we're entering trance
with each precision [ __ ] were precision
hits sorry
reducing the cooldown of your super and
the knife juggler grants super energy so
each precision hit of just like normal
guns or reduce the cooldown stack limit
increased from three to five super gen
modifier increased by 20% so they're
really wanting to give you this the
super and lets you just blow some stuff
up which is kind of Awesome
absolutely again just loving these buffs
making things explosive making things
more powerful absolutely love it so the
other one now I I will have to bite my
tongue to not say anything about this in
cursive all but for now we're just going
to talk about the patch changes and then
we'll get to crucible a bit later
bleh brush
so we've got impact damage has been
decreased from 150 to 35 so when the
actual knives are thrown the impact
itself is less damage at first so it's
not gonna be that the quick kill it's
gonna be the explosive damage goes from
150 to 250 so the delay is a little bit
there it's not just like complete
wipeout I guess so I guess they want a
little bit of a delay on that one mm-hmm
what do you see it does it changes the
nature of the super completely obviously
that delayed reaction explosive damage
you know I will say that yeah I was able
to escape a few times more and then get
killed when you're yeah exactly this is
a it changes it you know listen we know
it was strong was it necessarily this I
don't know you know I'm saying I mean
how do you feel about it I I haven't
played 100 nearly as much for basically
from forsaken on so I don't really have
a point of reference as much for PvE
well that's I guess my big curiosity
just how this thing feels in PvE I mean
it was like it was pretty powerful for
the chunk of damage you would see fall
off when this thing like I mean it will
be a little slower in their reaction I
mean the explosion for 150 to 250 but I
mean it goes up by a hundred but it
drops by a hundred and fifteen so I'm
like it's close to a give and take
I don't know no I agree I agree it was
like I just I don't know the full feel
in PvE just because I haven't been
playing it that like hardly at all but
it still feels like they tried to
balance it just delay it which it's kind
of an odd choice but I guess it works
it's they had a reason I'm never
entirely sure why on some yeah it's a
strange design choice I will admit I
didn't I didn't think they would attack
it in this way so it is they did turn it
into a nova bomb oops you killed
yourself moment though so it now deals
self damage so our goal for the AoE
supers of this type is that they incur
self damage when activated too close to
a target basically they don't want you
to have a panic blade barrage or if you
do panic blade brush it's gonna be a
trade right which i think is fair that's
fair because this thing is already
broken enough in PvP which I'll get to
but basically in other words hunters
will know what it feels like when
warlocks throw Nova bomb into a wall
which is the Demery perfect I gotta
catch you to dude is coming for you to
chat he said I haven't used my Hunter at
all lately hey I haven't been used I've
actually been sucking on my warlock for
a while surprise he's making the
intelligent decision to do it yesterday
he's living the good life right now let
his best life as well hey if you're
working on a solo shatter throne well of
Radiance is to argue with okay
solo reason bro tell you right now well
I could solo pretty much anything well
radiates in lieu de faction boots like
that is my solo lineup you can solo just
about everything so we're gonna have you
record your song after this with that
talk so nerdy bond tsk we're not the end
great known as esoteric and that stuff
you know I know my limitations but like
I said well III feel confident when I'm
by myself with that load output continue
back back to the hunters you know what
it's like I mean the hunters fun it's
just one of those for me I've been I
haven't played it as much and for me
it's like it's it's it about 588 I
haven't quite maxed it out so it's just
like different time to put in and with
so much stuff going on lately it's just
one thing stacking on the next like it
was always every forge to work on doing
and then I'm like I'd rather grind out
blast furnace then work on leveling my
hunter so my priorities have been other
places because I have two characters I
can still do plenty of stuff I don't
have time to do everything anyway if I
was like running out of stuff maybe but
I have so much time there's so much
stuff to do in no time I should say that
I said they're backwards good to you
what else we got
next is the hunter Night Stalker the
Mobile River southern targets now have
the full damage increase rather than
needing to be tethered by multiple
shadow shots which is nice
additionally the shadow shot damage
bonus to tether targets was increased
increased Mobius quiver to other target
radius by 20%
Mobius quiver tether lifetime and may is
it easier to fire successive shadow
shots so across the board yeah combien
board nice change
yeah so just tether be a little bit more
powerful less and longer just gives it a
bit more life which overall I think is
just a good thing gives this tree just a
little bit more love which it basically
needed so spectral blade super bonus
damage resistance while in stealth
decreased from 15 percent to 5 percent
they're still hard to kill I still say
he ain't that much of a [ __ ] and
they still hard to kill man obviously is
coming to charge in Hawaii I'll be on
little unloading the clip and they still
just read the next line while in special
blades and in spell total damage
resistance is 62% it's like it's still
crazy so I mean they survived because I
mean I can see the cloak guy running at
me it doesn't matter what I do I was
like I'll shoot him shoot him shoot him
and then I don't know it's like swipe
your gums and like I'll even be shooting
my like retold tail void shut gun into
his face as he comes out being that
matter yeah do a damn thing undo
anything completely agree now it says
the total super Asian while invisible
decreased by 3 point 6 7 seconds I love
how they have that I mean I love how
they're giving us that specific but it
sounds like 3 seconds off a super
actually is a lot but it still feels
like those guys get to run forever so
I'm like what was it yeah what was it
before right because he spilled even
another me yeah I still feel like it's a
landing to super there's no doubt yeah
it's just like uh guys so yeah it's been
the hunters will say your other two got
a lot of love and then we're gonna talk
about this last one but solar hunter
like if you worry as a Titan or as a
hunter just go solar and I think you're
gonna be fine it's all I guess a artist
writer Ark staff super heavy ranged in
slam attacks damage increased from 220
to 300 heavy bomb blast attack damage
increased from 400 to 700 C I don't have
a point of reference if that's PvE or
PvP or what a job of a like I don't like
how they just throw out these random
numbers and then it's just they're not
saying specifically PVE pvp you know
saying we gotta play the guessing game
with certain things but whatever I don't
see then I'm
assume that it's across the board right
so yeah it's like is that like a base
number then PV is multiplied with like
power level cuz I mean you'll shoot some
people and I'll do like all I don't know
like thousands of damage so I'm like I
know this isn't exactly right and I'm
not just like I'm not gonna like wail on
a boss and a strike for 400 damage it's
gonna take six years so yeah it's it's a
weird point of reference number wise
that's why I was like again Bungie
giving us some numbers but it's like it
doesn't quite have it all sometimes just
a little bit mmm well it's the lethal
current bonus hit damage and piece
increased from 130 which I have no point
of reference like telling me something
weighs like 300 elephants it's like I
thought I heard that recently in a video
in somebody's life I'm just saying why
tell me that like I don't know how to
first place much less what 300 ways of
what I could like perceive that to be so
it's like vintage Bungie isms 0.07% days
yeah like we increase you auto ride i
probe damage by seven hundred seven
percent and i'm like what you're gonna
take one more hair off my arm if i miss
like what that doesn't do anything in my
for them apparently i did clearly uh
radiant flux exotic armor damage bonus
decreased from 20% to 13.5 this change
keeps the bow two statements granted by
this exotic about the same because this
is calculator not a scaler instead of a
flat number any big changes in base
damage have a large effect on this
exotic so yeah the image was bumped so
therefore they brought the exotic down
so i guess it wasn't broken but granted
the way golden gun can do what it can do
why'd you have to take anything down
here this like honestly arc starter
doesn't hardly get used much anyway like
some people use a brad clearing but
seriously like why nothing needed to go
down here it's not like it's i think
what they realize is when flux was on
with these update it was probably really
ignorant but that might give more people
to use it as variety because generally
it still a few little six shots taking
powered golden good and relax yourself
you guys got a lot right now you want
the perfect every subclass no no i'm
just said no I'm just saying like Golden
Gun is Golden Gun and blade brushes like
just busted right now and we'll talk
about mayhem as to why but like or
stridor I just never see them so it's
just one of those those like I don't I
just don't feel it nerve was justified
before it I don't even play the under
much right now
I just don't feel this is benefiting
that class and really I don't think it
was required at all like if somebody was
just like Oh radiant flux does a lot of
damage that might give people more
variety cuz you still have to get in the
mix you still have to get up there and
we're talking about six and a half
percent like not that much greater
multiplied only ever reason to use the
ox rider he agrees with you
yeah so that's all more just the idea of
when you go through and do a pass like
yeah it's just one of those like it was
there was almost good and it's still
good but you know all right so tighten
now I haven't even played by Titan this
week I have been just working on the
warlock because all my quests are all on
the warlock so I'm stuck there for now
uh Titan sunbreaker sunspots damage
increased from 25 to 50 per tick yes I
guess the sunspots on the ground for
enemies standing in them the Sun warrior
perk buff now increases all damage
output from Sun breaker by 2014 and ATP
25% in PvE mmm buff duration has been
increased from 3 to 5 seconds mmm that's
that's a deal that's a deal right yeah
that's a chunk right there so so the Sun
warrior perk is the one we're working
down at the bottom tree and this is
passing through a sunspot causes all
your solar abilities to recharge faster
and you're super to last longer it also
increases the damage you do so yeah 20%
bonus and 25% PvE plastic you may not
throw as many hammers but they're gonna
hit harder and the buff lasts longer if
you pass through it so I mean that's not
bad
I bet no man might give me a reason to
try it I still don't know if I'll use it
as much as like I feel like top tree I
can just throw more yeh then some of
them it's just fun to first and just the
explosion on the explosive pyre on the
top tree is it's hard to not use that
because if you're throwing it into a
groups like the first one you hit and
that explosion kills of a group and it's
like not having that I don't know so
maybe making the solar sunspot maybe
balances a little bit out but you know
that's the thing
so a Sun warrior just talked about so
burning Maul super now this is
honestly you don't see much of FCIC like
I'm saying
Wow I see it sometimes in PvP and I'll
be like oh yeah he's got that one these
matches the kind of tracks towards me
was like oh yeah I forgot it does that
because I don't see it enough to
remember I always forget I'm like aha
yeah well now spin melee attack damage
increased from 65 to 80 per hit so a
boost there and again this is I don't
know what this reference is but a boost
people say we're gonna oh yeah
slam detonation radius increased from 5
to 6 meters so a bigger slam which is
gonna make those PvE moments a little a
little bigger in the PvP moments a
little wider and then the improve slam
attack projectile tracking so that fire
that tracks you across the ground if
you're in a circle map guess what it's
making that corner there go very
aggressive you know hunt you down I've
been victimized by ya burnin wall I've
seen the effects yeah so that one I
still feel like it's an underutilized
like that is probably the one super of
all the new ones and forsaken that got
used the least i KS reaches a B spectral
blades Nova warp you've got well of
radiance and that was just sitting out
there like Oh guys I'm new I'm new look
at me LA and it's just an it's
overlooked it's just out of it yeah it's
like because you can throw hammers and
range in PvP and that is just our PvE
and there's nothing like doing that
damage from across the map and being
safe as opposed to have to slam the
ground close to whatever you're giving
it to you because you can't get close to
any boss in destiny not hardly close
enough or if they float or whatever it's
like the tornado across the ground it's
just it doesn't quite have the same
effect so we'll see if it gets a little
love
pretty Titan we've got B Sentinel Titan
so the shield super final melee combo
hit damage increase from 300 to 390
damage to PvE competin is increased by
17% where they get some of these numbers
sometimes I'm always curious but they're
their data worlds they take six years to
come up with them so they got it from
something mmm
now I don't know if you've seen the
video but shadow etheric oh it's brown
awesome back to the Android known as
esoteric that's
oh my god it was ridiculous we showed up
with the whisper one right yeah you
would you can say it you know one of the
striking things through the entire
orders or three rooms like I was like
this is insane
and it just literally kept regenerate
and regenerate Interjet that's insane
yeah so it's the is it just the fist of
havoc I'm trying to remember where or so
it reduced the shoulder charge cost of
the code of the juggernut by 83% yes and
then I guess doing that as well there's
a way to I'm looking at up real quick it
is insane man if you got see this thing
again he's doing the whisper of the worm
quest he's in that strike it tight and
literally he's just killing ads killing
taking getting the super back getting
the super babies like the the bar will
not go down it was it's go down and it
goes up it goes down it goes up but it
stays doing the duration it is insane
see that thing gonna work like that yeah
so I think it's the bottom tree vamper
trample destroying enemies with fist of
havoc extends its variational normal if
you slam it takes a chunk of your super
to you know obviously slam once but he's
just doing this shoulder charge effect
which had it's like energy charge
reduced by basically almost everything
so it's like 17 percent of what it used
to be right but not much and then if you
sit there and just keep killing and he
just keeps building that super energy
backup runs around smacks a heavy a
couple times kills them go find some low
enemies dum-dum-dum-dum
comes back go kills a big night it's
like that room with all the purple I
call it the purple rooms when I do my
video but it's like the third room yeah
just every shadow throw it goes kills
like three of those round ghost kills a
night shadow thralls tonight shadows
rolls tonight acolytes acolytes with I'm
just like dude I wouldn't even thought
of that either - so to be he's a beast
even think about oh yeah it's like just
even come up with it but I just watch
that and I'm just like damn about that
so time and I wasn't befitting I
recommend you all you guys see it man
really showcases what that buff can do
and that's crazy
carried a tightness in PvE it's really
dominant so yeah that's the code of the
judgement
not perk up above we had fist of havoc
super the heavy slam attack which is you
know your big one base damage decrease
from three twenty five seventy five
which is odd interesting damage base to
elite mini-boss and combatants increased
by 7% which feels like the base went
down but the mini-boss went up and
increased damage to bosses by 23% mm-hmm
I don't mind I like that I should I
increase damage to vehicles by sixty
percent and I'm like okay it's not gonna
be like the like tank walkers and stuff
like walkers and all that stuff probably
just doesn't do enough if it's not a
crate or something like that say I don't
think people run around looking for um
wisdom fallen vehicles there was the
spider tanks or whatever that Peter
bikes at the fall of now yeah yeah heavy
yeah whatever bikes or whatever yeah I
don't think we gonna be running around
looking for that but nobody no I can see
that because at the end of the day it's
a super day you generally don't use all
bosses like that so that to make it a
little bit more viable against single
you know difficult shot targets yeah
it's pretty cool it's just like why like
they decrease the damage and then they
buff didn't I'm late it's a streams I
don't see those are like the I was like
there's something in their systems where
it's a base number multiplied by what
level it like something happens
somewhere in the background where
they're lowering something and bringing
other things up but it seems like why'd
you have to lower it in the first place
like those I don't know so exactly it's
odd but those are those are ones that I
wish they would be like I wish they had
some text after this to explain what it
means of course we're asking like the
point of reference had numbers to be
like oh hey we lowered the heavy base
attack because with these increases in
damage so and so sometimes they throw
that in but then it's like not always
there so just be a little more one of
those things where you kind of need did
the developer commentary because to
really explain the thought process
behind it because again it's cool that
they're being transparent with the
numbers but at the same time what's the
reasoning what's the thought process
great that they actually would do it a
good job of that maybe about the last to
twelve before they would actually
mention stuff like this and say hey
thought process was da-da-da-da-da that
kind of thing
now it's like you know what happened to
that so that's why we still we've seen a
little confused yeah
terminology but changed the way the
bonus damage from this perk is granted
at 1/3 threshold tier based on how long
you're in the air before impact so
higher you are the more damage you get
arc damage per hits per tier increase
from 3 to 4 which is I don't even know
well arc damage hits per tier I guess
tier 1 4 hits tier 2 eight hits tier 3
12 hits increased arc damage hit from
100 to 112 and so again those are all
like the base dam numbers but it's just
how high you are in the air and they
basically described it as like your
normal ones 1 and if you kind of like
jump and kind of do it at the height 2
and then 3 you've got to get you've got
to be like maybe flying off of like a
couple storey building to really slam
down and get that big boost but if you
do then you know you're gonna get the
joys of a giant giant slam which is kind
of cool gives you a little perk for
being up high if you can find a way to
get there
absolutely alright mmm
trampled perk which is the one I was
talking about as well okay now trigger
they were to energy return every 0.5
seconds up from one second so that's
that those two together the shoulder
charge lower and the trample perk like
that's how a so Taric did its thing but
shut out cuz that's awesome and I'm
gonna pass this over to my warlock my
real or a lot brother and let him talk
about some Boyd Walker action yeah let's
get to it so I get Cataclysm Nova bomb
initial detonation damage increased from
900 to 1500 hmm detonation radius
increased from 8 to 10 meters seeker
projectile debt nation damage increased
from 205 to 300 that's a big deal our
improved seeker projectile turning
radius and homing to make it more
consistent to use against bosses and
single targets and then last one is
fixed an issue where secret projectiles
could be permanently damaged this is
huge across the board cuz I mean let me
tell you something Slovo as I call it
slow really didn't have any problems
before like Slava I was actually very
effective with it and it's you know
pretty buff state now you're talking
about damage increase range increase and
then after the initial explosion those
saw projectiles that go out being like a
grass
Sibley hunting you more this is a big
deal right I used to use this I put like
this if you got skull of almond caramel
with this and like like we should do
that with escalation protocol and just
melt like cuz you just killing yellow
bars getting stuff back and in crucible
whoo powerful powerful yeah this is a
big deal I was actually surprised they
felt the need to give top tree
voidwalker this I felt it was fine as it
was but I ain't complaining like I used
it yesterday I was running around
working on public events basically and
like ever like every boss of every
public event I just was one shot in them
why Nick almost on my own like cuz it be
boom there's 2/3 little projectiles turn
come back into the guy in the middle and
wow yeah hey here's the thing what about
um have you been using it with Scholl no
I don't even ask oh well
no I don't know if I do I'd have to dig
my and wait for Scott waiting for user
video to come out to tell me what skulls
you tell me yo car gets out I'm logging
in that's all I've been missing since I
came over it's one of the few of
admission since I came over you see and
I'm it is is it she it feels like a
Chico it feels like you're cheating the
game because literally you'll know the
bomb one or two yellow bars and have 80%
of their super right back sometimes 100
like doing escalation or anything with
just bosses and bosses or yelling oh my
god
yeah and now they're doing this but
anyway we continue but yet if this is a
big deal so they they're definitely
making this super viable so then we got
the Nova bomb itself which is I guess
bomb tree an issue detonation damage
increase from 900 to 1200 and lingering
volume damage increase from 10 to 23 per
tick big deal big deal
and now the fun fun is over y'all put
your drinks up the rest a little rest in
peace shout out to the Nova wall
we had our fun bros we had our fun lore
but uh it's come to an end
slightly slowed movement while charging
charging costs more energy initial
charge cost each time we trigger your
super increased by 6
steep ascent sustained rain costs off
for those running around charging it up
looking for B will increase by 60%
duration decreased by 6 plate 8 seconds
Jesus noble noble wiping the team and
then looking for more decrease super
damage resistance from 56 to 54 ok
whatever damage against Guardians
decreased by 27% let me get a drink real
quickly because I got a little red all
right we'll say before you do get in I
will say people who do play it say like
people wanted it brought in check and
I'm pretty sure and I'll let you go that
they kind of cut it off at the knees so
go ahead a low point lovely oh yo boy
bros we gotta talk about it yeah I
played it's it's it's not the same it's
not the same that the key I understand
it duration I'm cool with that it's the
charge cost man like like before like
you know you hold it down you know you
try to get somebody you get the
explosion and now even when you charge
sometimes it doesn't kill all the time
now so I'm a little worried you know the
band the band Hammett came down pretty
hard and nerve hammer came down pretty
hard on it you know is it not effective
no it's still effective it's still
effective I mean if you can kept the
thing now is what I would advise these
guys still using it I would say when
Nick when people are clumped up you got
it you have to use it pretty much and
immediately and then hope to get lucky I
still catch another catch a 2 2 3 now
you're not catching six people and five
people like unless they're all in one
spot you know I'm saying doing yeah
that's it you know unless they're doing
the last word of quest where no one
wants to engage and everyone stays in I
will say like I had some matches or like
people run as a team and just reckon us
and be like hey they just maybe it must
be quickly and I had that one match
where
like I feel like everybody's on this
damn quest cuz it was literally like two
sides of a volleyball court and no one
would cross the middle
it was literally following what we don't
get infected I got a lot to say about
that and I experienced it with Nova
we'll put everything the probably right
now just last thing I'll say on is that
everything costs it costs so much to
blink to warp to charge so is it a
shout-out to I believe is a Jenga
moniker Chad they're gonna need they're
gonna be like an exotic to compensate
something cuz it's it's just yeah it's
not it's not good boys it's not good I'm
sorry to tell you I did try it now what
is good is dawn blade daybreak super
increased damage against minor major and
mini-boss combatants by 43% it is beast
in PvE I trust that increase duration by
3 seconds you know warm blade I'm tell
you right now if you don't got a chance
oh man yeah who don't belong man and
that's what I was running working on my
stuff actually dawn blade last long
especially using bottom tree dawn play
where you get the kill and it's giving
you um super mg back very strong so dawn
blade is the way to go even for PvP
dude's got his violin rare for right now
alright stormcaller we got the storm
track super increase Chain Lightning
maximum target count by 1 mini rant um
this is wack yo this is trash I don't
like it
like still storm quality and get enough
love that stormcaller was the class that
needed it in my opinion and top tree
door blade those are the classes that
needed because tickle fingers ain't hurt
nobody nobody scared a tickle fingers :
you know like and you got the whole I
mean if you're using crown attempt it's
ok but if you're gonna increase the
maximum count by 1 you got at least do
more day still doesn't you enough damage
man and then Pete didn't the length of
it people run away like it is so easy to
run away from a storm trance yeah don't
trance is still a lot of work so my only
thing with that loud finish up was just
that in a top I thought top top
dawn blade would get some love and he
didn't get anything so it seems like
they put all their thing into killing
Nova work yeah it's like they really
want to kill Nova walk bless Nova
Cataclysm Slover but didn't do nothing
with the other two and as a wall I feel
a way about this all the other classes
for the most part you know they touched
with their other sub you know it went a
little bit more in-depth per year but
it's like it seems with us it was just
the focus was on the void lock and not
really anything else so I'm a little as
a welcomed a little disappointed with
the other lack of subclass oh yeah it's
like they were like okay so we've got
three months to do this alright sweet we
spent two months in two weeks on the
other two super it's crap we have two
more two more classes uh and they
literally just put the last like a
weekend each like I know that's not how
it went down I know there's priorities
for the big supers but it feels like
yeah they put I mean look a bit like one
list here daybreak super like I mean
bottom tree Don blade feels cool but as
he said the top one tickle fingers stuff
like that like couple things were yeah
yeah it's high they got neglected how
come week for top tree the whole thing
is about being in the air right and
getting your energies your abilities
back how can get something within ear
accuracy how come we couldn't we could I
got something you know saying like
bottom tree storm Doble is stay break
it's just so much more appealing like I
don't know what's the reason and the
same thing with like I guess I guess top
tree stormcaller here you can blink
against an EVP but people running trust
me it has such limited range you're not
catching nobody with tickle fingers you
know one's scared to tickle fingers like
that man they got to do somebody so
that's what I got what weapons to it
I'll let you grab it yeah so I mean but
I mean that's just even multiple heel
and Chad said Fred Scott heard scope
just a lot of people say and it's like I
mean they took Nova warp and like it
needed brought in line but they
literally nerfed it so that no one's
gonna use it and unfortunately on the
other side I mean does anybody use the
thing in PvE I never use no because is
so it's really useless now because the
problem is it never was good against
single target dps like
you're not no for warping Saul's not
gonna happen anyway but like you know
it's just you know so it's just again I
don't want to come up as to complain
complain that it's just like this one
surprised me how hard it got hate house
and it's tough there's just like this
has been minute well guess what it's not
even gonna be close to it now that's
what we got so maybe a little up too
high a little too down low but yeah that
is that is the overall supers what do
you feel about the I mean I know we got
your thoughts about number one but the
general super changes how are you
feeling listen overall I mean outside of
my favorite some are very good I mean
yeah this is good stuff
you know you want to see this stuff I
love you know shout out to the hunters
like this is your time you know I'm all
about that Golden Gun getting their love
like I've always thought that was one of
the coolest you know mean supers and
just to see you know it do what it do is
really cool Titans around here we
already see when esoteric is doing you
know the Sun I love with the Sun
breaking stuff even burning more or less
in love I like the balance you know
overall and I like to see them continue
to do this thing if they do this like
say for example Orion odd we they'd put
this out genuine we're February now
let's say come March it should be like
every two months Kate it's two to three
month cadence right we should get stuff
like this you you an elastic got the
data pull it out say okay what's not
being used what's going on and keep
going if destiny does that trust me
people get excited man people get
excited to see changes so you know
overall still feel it was good yeah but
it's like the last time they did
something like this sorry to control it
don't know but it's like when's the last
time they did something this big patch
wise was it forsaken right pretty much
and that that cadence right there as you
said five months too long like that's
that's the stagnation that happens it's
like how long has Nova war been just
dominant and it's like now it's like so
nerfed into the ground you have to
wonder like was it gonna be in the like
is it gonna be September when like no
war might have a thing again like and
that's the unfortunate thing of their
current pacing though
at least some of us to say like well
when is this if something isn't right if
we're like hey they changed something
way too far they didn't do enough to
storm trance it's like a storm Karl are
still gonna suck for another six months
like that's kind of what sucks about the
big change unfortunately
like taking this long the next one's
gonna be that much longer
yeah and you would hope not I mean
that's the thing you would hold men the
same thing with useless exotic armor
like they've got this armor just sitting
in my volt oh my god yeah we'll get it
we won't even start that but you
it's that same vein they've got to pick
up cadence cuz they've got things and if
they just tweak you will reenergize this
can you look at what they did when they
when the moon was the Gravitron Lance
the the what is it the Sun shot and I
forgot what the third gun was at the
suite business nobody remembers that one
like they really buffed it right and you
like you know like it's really useful
like they need those type of things that
we energizes the game so let's see
fingers crossed man you're hoping that
they can stay on a consistent cadence uh
so yeah supers will see whenever a
change comes but definitely spend your
time test all your trees test all your
like subclasses like upper or lower like
maybe a tree you didn't use go chat test
it out because some of those are beastly
now yeah and then others need to be put
in the locker and left there for a while
but weapons we also got some changes
here mm-hmm
so I have not touched auto rifles yet to
have you okay alright so I'll let you
touch this one because I've actually
clutched the next one alright so pretty
much I'm saying touch sorry got you
that's what it is okay now it's getting
creepy you know auto rifles increased
base damage or the rapid-fire ones by
nine percent then we got the base damage
on the high impact by 5% and increased
base damage on adaptive auto rifles by
six percent so these were okay I've been
messing around with this a bit um the
thing that hurts is that a lot of the
auto rifles I like tend to
fall into the precision class aka what
does it break neck you know what I'm
saying so though that'd be the high
impact on no break neck is actually um
precision frame oh well I got rapid high
impacted I forgot there were four geared
or this four so the thing is I didn't
get a chance I messed with
um rapid-fire that felt good um again
this pv stuff adaptive that felt good
now the thing I notice - um there's a
I'm gonna give you a little secret right
now um use what you call it um it's a
it's a forged weapon to forge Auto so I
have to pull up them right now it's got
a green or the weird numbers yeah it's a
it's a it's a forge Auto right now that
I don't know what if it's the role that
I'm using or whatever it is what this
thing is beast I'm gonna give you a
little gem on it this is at the Galliard
42 that one this is that you can only
get this from black armory also I'm
saying there are there's the ones with
the numbers that drop or there's like
the powerful frames the powerful frame
or email oh yes ringing ringing ringing
ela and I don't know if it falls it ring
it I don't know what's going on ringing
there but please yeah I need to try that
in the crucible is something about it I
don't know and I got a garbage role my
role is trash but yeah ringing male
right now if you guys have that dusted
off put it in the crucible let me know
how you guys think because I was playing
with a couple of guys and it was insane
what I was doing it almost feels like
the range maybe cuz it's a it's a
long-range auto didn't get away with
stuff but overall my feeling was like
okay you know it's slight buff I still
didn't feel that dominate especially
with the last word matter right now so
you know I over all I don't know if this
was the the biggest impact but I still
have to mess around a couple more auto
rifles before I make a full decision on
the archetype but yeah somebody in chats
and Valcke it in like old school one
like that year one I've got a troll on
Valken I actually want to just go look I
have a hammer forged rifling flared
magwell outlaw rampage
and that's just like an old Auto rifle
I'm like well I got a good roll maybe I
will go try that in PvP so yeah
apparently auto rifles need to get
looked at because I don't know they just
they haven't had that much love so maybe
this will help but I guess we'll see how
it goes I haven't used them that I
haven't used I've still been stuck on
pretty much my pulse rifle for PvE
so we'll see how that goes but maybe
maybe apparently from you and some
others saying some of this stuff is fun
sweet business having you in touch that
yet I don't even know what that I don't
even know what that's considered
rapid-fire Academy I guess yeah nine
percent on that one maybe that's good
mmm shout out to all the dude he said a
question while breakneck is a 450 AR do
we know if when on slider activated 670
changes apply I've been messing a lot
with breakneck um I didn't notice any
difference to be honest I think it feels
like they're still treating it like a
precision frame 450 which didn't get the
buff so I didn't feel like oh man it's
doing something way more than it
normally does it's still beast once you
got onslaught kicking in and I'm saying
so that's my field I feels like the
Precision's have been left alone but for
whatever reason precision autos feel
good like they I mean especially they're
ringing me I don't know what it is about
that gun but whatever but what you got
it right take it exactly well we don't
so scout rifles you got lightweight
scout rifles by 5% base damage on rapid
fire Scouts by 6 percent and increased
scout rifle damage PvE by 10% I haven't
use scouts in PvE but I will say okay
well I will say my piece on this first
if you have a black scorpion pull that
thing out for PvP it's fun really fast
oh yeah you'll kill them quick okay so
I've been having some fun with that one
in PvP it's it's just long enough range
and you get those like like four or five
shots man it's like it's in there so
quick but how's the PvE feel on these
things that's the big question I would
touch the scout in ages yeah but mr.
roske out feel good Scouts feel good I
cannot lie like um I did just the
overall PD I've got the one right now
that I've dust off as a
if you guys got distant relation with
some good rolls man your distant
relation feels good yeah obviously the
old-school armed nameless midnight you
know I still I dusted off a couple of
those old-school rolls put those back
out there um
Polaris feeling strong what's up guy um
you know definitely Scouts you I see the
difference you know I'm saying so I've
been rocking a lot of like triple tap
stuff a lot of explosive damage kind of
stuff rampage kind of stuff and it's
been feeling good from a distance so
yeah I definitely feel Scouts are viable
for sure in PvE definitely you know in
PvP they're okay they've improved but
then again I don't have the vodka ting
like you said cuz that's that specific
one you know saying you know with the
rapid fire I don't think I have too many
of those archetype a scout so I have to
try that out once I get up get my hands
on it but overall I do feel a nice bump
to scouts nice mm-hmm
tackle the next winner sniper rifles
increased base damage of a rapid-fire
sniper rifles by 8% you can to shop body
to defeat other Guardians in PvP yeah
that's true
Oh bro let me tell ya who's in the
crucible yo snipers are back with a
vengeance
oh my lord I'm waking up in cold sweats
right now in a way it's good because
let's be real we haven't seen them in so
long so as much as I'm in my feelings
about getting killed by it a lot you
know the reality is you know it
definitely is you feel the difference
man and I don't if it's weird because I
don't feel like they did I feel like
they did something to the flinch in the
sense that I'm shooting guys they'll pop
out and pop back in and still pop me
with a sniper so those rapid fires right
now I forgot this to in particular I'm
just forgetting the name off top but um
man yo snipers are back I'm telling you
it's scary out there
in a way it is good to see because they
have they have been missed it I have to
play out to adjust my playstyle
big time so I don't know if you've
encountered them at all
yet you know uh I must have been one of
the first games I went into granted like
I'll always give like props to a sniper
yeah I'm usually they're killing me
closer than I ever feel like it should
be functional in this game so yes um in
my chat assay and supremacy is nasty I
can imagine actually on that one
it always is so it's probably been worse
but no like snipers they they are a they
are not option I think is the best way I
can say it I still get a lot of depends
on the map and stuff but I'm seeing them
I'm seeing those little sniper glows a
lot more on their horizon out there so
it's it's definitely a thing you got a
you got to play a little differently
because I'm just like peek in places I'm
like where did and then just and then
finally you kind of see the little like
you're like oh and you're in your death
screen and you're like damn and I'm just
and I'll be even like live on stream i
don't even care i'm like that's just the
day I'm a good shot nice job it was like
I don't care it's like if somebody kills
we I will say if someone kills me with a
sniper in this game the whole drag
scoping is kind of weird to me which is
still not the way I think a sniper
should work yeah there's that whole like
stickiness over the head and it's like
and you literally watch like the pros
like the epic people they'll be next to
some of me and they do the pull across
and fire and I'm like that's just that's
not the way one should function I know
that's how they are in this game but the
people who have mastered that skill
either way just hats off to the talent
let's be real I mean you know the
rapid-fire archetype was completely
underused you know I mean so to see that
kind of come to a vengeance and have a
place now because let's be real you
wouldn't really take that in PvE right
so now they're making rap bias the PvP
god so to speak and I actually don't
have a problem with it you know shout to
dizzy he was like he's got the double
explosive bow as a good counter to those
sniper your bowls are still strong we'll
get into that put on yeah I'm telling
you right now like I've been waking up
with cold sweats with these snipers man
they they're playing tactical and you
just got a tip your cap cap off and
you're like you know what they're back I
gotta I gotta just gotta just so you
shot that let's see grenade launchers
tweet grenade launcher projectiles to
feel more consistent on direct hits
proximity grenades can no longer impact
directly prevent special ammo grenade
launchers from one-shotting with the
perk active and then increased ammo
serve sizes special ammo grenade
launchers increased initial spawn in PvE
for special ammo grenade launchers
mm-hmm all seeming like decent things I
don't think it's good better otherwise
so listen Bo's made the effect of the
draw time from bowstring pertz more
noticeable height engine straining
flexible the accuracy stabbed from high
tension was increased from 10 to 15 so
just a little tweaks there on the bows I
mean I was I still bows for me or
something like I never thought I'd like
but if I'm just running around like I'll
go through shattered throne with my go
figure with my subtle calamity and
Thunder Lord and I literally sold the
whole thing with almost those except for
the final room I have to switch off of
my bow but I can almost use my bow for
like the whole fight a child is even
he's the boat king i watch him and he's
that's all he does man IV at the end of
the day uh I don't I got to get over my
mental thing I just got to start using
him I don't know what it is cuz when I
did use them they were very effective
hmm yes I just got like I got like bow
bias I got to get over myself like this
is space magic I don't want to use a
string in an arrow what's happened dude
it's just your Guardians pulling a bow
it's got some moment it's like something
basically happens like a discarded trash
really sorry I got a stop I've really
gotta start playing with bows now I
really do because I'm getting killed by
them and I do see them in a crucible
also um yeah balls just are really good
you know to be honest like bows are so
dominant that's why I'm glad Scouts got
the buff because bows are really
occupying that space like better you
know saying but you know that's just me
yeah I was like my subtle calamity
dragonfly and explosive head that's just
a lot of fun legend legend makes a
return legend that creates increased
range increased by 0.5 meters PvE damage
increased by 50% large yo you might want
to bust that thing out and see if it
hits hard
I'm have to get Leviathan gun on PC
sounds like I got it done so I'm pretty
much I just I don't care about the
ornament so I haven't done the person
that probably should but I haven't but
as for the gun I have the thing so I
should probably test it out shout out to
ask across got a great video right now
on a curious it is really disgusting the
range it is really disgusting the damage
that you're doing in PVE it is super
viable like a Chris is back and embedded
in effort like please if you guys have
it dusted off man
a Chris is a problem I'm seeing him
taking like 75% to 80% of life wanted
yellow bars
it's crazy what you're doing now okay
it's it's crazy and then I'll tell it
you I'll let you take your babies go for
it yes another one flip some liquor
again I mean this is coming Telesto
reduced base damage for each bolt by 19%
increase optic staff from 15 to 20 to be
comparable with other fusion rifles with
scopes PvE damage increased by 30% so on
haven't seen it in PvE ever really mess
around with it too much but uh PvP oh
it's a joke this is another this it is
so nerfed to the ground like someone
shot a shoot like it was like they
literally laughed I was like it didn't
have any effect it didn't have the the
extra umph that it normally has Telesto
is officially dead stow in PvP that's
that's a wrap that get shrekt listen for
people who you know people who feel as
cheesy and they gonna be happy you know
this is this is no longer part of the
meta so um I don't know how you feel
about it but I think the fact I like the
fact that they at least increase the PvE
damage so make it a little bit more
viable based I wanna test that part out
just to see you know how that goes but
what did you needed didn't need to
happen from what I heard it was I mean I
never faced it that much but the times I
did there's probably one time towards
the end of light as it was wrapping up
this like season of Terror it was just
it think somebody killed me with him so
far away I'm like yeah this needs to get
fixed so because what those and I didn't
even I didn't face it that often because
I was mostly quickly I don't do
competitive that's just not my thing I
am probably awful in there but no there
was one like in the probably the past
month or so and just one kill that I can
just remember us like yeah it's about
time that's done cuz that that that one
kill it was like
yep that's not right in the day I gotta
be full disclosure I was one on console
I was one of those sweats
I had the ill oh my god it was it was
bad what I was doing I felt bad like I
was like I shouldn't be doing this to
people
it was Telesto Naza Rex in and I was
just getting my super and I had like
super mods and she's getting double kit
it was really because I didn't have
Lunas house so that was my like build to
stop long as how it was literally 2 less
though and you know it's super sweaty
super cheesy built and yeah it's you
know it had a nice run it was good while
it lasted
got a day get adjust that kinda move on
to something else and something else
trace rifles so trace rifles gain
additional ammo when picking up special
ammo because those things do burn
through it and I know we don't have the
fancy wave splitter here on the world of
PC but even the other two if I take them
into PvP I've just been like I have no I
never had ammo so yeah it's uh that's a
good thing and then reduced damage of
wave splitter against Guardians medium
damage 19% high damage 27% these are big
numbers I don't have the gun but I here
on PlayStation this thing is kind of
busted it's gonna make me um bust out
what you call it though I mean you know
what it is I still actually played with
a Prometheus and um actually just
prometheus
I noticed the the effects of traces you
know saying they feel good but I still
feel they don't have enough ammo no they
just burn through it so fast cuz you're
trying to draw that line and I'm like
outlining the person without killing
them the whole time so all my animals on
the wall behind them but yeah they could
definitely always use more ammo because
you just burn through it so fastest Oh
facts Crisco but he said Joe toon has
cooked Telesto spy be facts now that's
what need to be talked about is Daniel
Yergin
yotan whatever it's called that it's
disgusting right now like oh my I
digress continue yeah nope you know that
exotic has joined a whole different
world of like I don't have it yet I
think my brother got it shadows my
brother putting in the grind but yeah I
don't have that one yet so we're still
waiting to get my drop we'll see
exotic armor tuned energy values on
shards of gallon or to accompany changes
to a blade where our super reduce
maximum energy returned from 90 to 75%
of the total super now only two returns
energy on the knife impacts I still call
garbage sauce on this one because it is
still broken as hell
[Music]
we reduced energy on the quiet invest
from ten to seven percent of the total
super so those were the two kind of
fairly broken exotics do you want to
talk about mayhem yet are we still
waiting cuz I'm like itching to but we
can still wait if you want
that's up to you go for it let's cool
well how much we got left and then we
can just kind of jump into alright we'll
wait we'll talk about crucible down
there alright put a pin in that for like
10 seconds guys
but yeah apparently there are some
tweaks made to those two supers I'm not
sure if they did a lot so we'll get to
that a second miscellaneous fixed
ability where players could retain super
energy for chaos reach even when being
suppressed mid super so I guess it was
almost counted as a turnoff so you still
got some back which I guess if you get
suppressed you should lose it that makes
sense yeah makes it fix an issue where
players could equip celestial nighthawk
mid super to partially benefit from the
half gosh i hack I'm like and something
that you could only do that on PC too
because there's no console could move
their menus fast enough and then there's
some other fixed issues with weapons but
crucible unless there's anything
important you want to fix in there but I
don't think I remember too much now all
right crucible Before we jump in just
what are your thoughts on crucible and
they had a lot to say so let's hear rant
right now oh let's do it
all you last word trash users trying to
get this last word really really
breaking the meta making my experience
completely uncomfortable shout out to
you dudes shall do you sweaty dudes all
six y'all and a bap it back in the map
not moving like it's a volleyball match
and dumb
yo it's rough out there cuz you got you
got this completely passive place now
then snipers are good now right so
people are literally
not to move because they don't want
their KD to go down in pursuit of the
last word so that's what I got to say
cuz we got to just get into it you know
so I know we're gonna touch last we're a
little bit but yeah I possibly trapped
in the class hit last when a crucible
dudes yeah like I don't know listen I
get it
you want the gun I get it it just really
sucks when an entire meta is playing
this way like do you know Buster like I
didn't play destiny for a while
jump dogs anthem came out jumped alright
you know all right boom started off my
quest okay let me get this let me get
that seeing what the steps are and I'm
like why is no one engaging like what is
going on and then I'm like oh it's the
KD people are not trying to lose it uh
it was rough it was rough for me I had a
a rough adjustment out the Forte shot
the kibosh on the screen it was rough
for me cuz I'm playing my normal way
okay guys let's fight nah I was standing
back and shoot you and I'm not moving
we're gonna team shot all day so my rant
is pretty much over so shouty dudes
could you please get your last word and
get back to playing normal please thank
you I'm dead that all you got waiting
two weeks so we'll start with the first
crucible and thank you Bungie for
messing with my weekly reset video by
the way I'll be like oh yeah so the
crucible playlist the week is gonna be
break through literally like 30 minutes
later it's mayhem online I'm like damn
it it does that weird thing sometimes
like I'll log in and it's like within
that first hour and I'm like I haven't
been like I didn't like leave it logged
in and log out I literally get home and
log in for the first time and stuff
hasn't updated nightfalls will change
sometimes this one changed I should have
known mayhem was coming if I remembered
but either way mm-hmm it was just weird
breakthrough fix an issue we're
deploying the breaker or hacking the
vault exactly the time expired kit in
the round an incorrect state whoa
breakthroughs still weird I don't know
if they ever fix the
scoring changes and all that stuff I
haven't gone back in to see if it's any
good because it's not there this week
but all in all liam breakthrough is
still just a weird mode because you have
either the stalemates or people form and
kills in the middle it's just kind of a
funky mode so heavy ammo tuning yeah
thoughts on this one it's interesting um
competitive you know they basically
across the board have reduced everything
the the timer from 45 to 129 I've been
paying a lot of competitor I haven't
played it recently since I've come back
this week but um just my thoughts based
on what I'm singing they don't want it
to dominate the flow of a match and I
think in theory it's to me it sounds
right in theory right are you playing a
lot of competitive you want it to be
more about the gun play you know but it
definitely used to feel that um what's
the word like um snowball effect when
the first group gets that heavy you know
45 seconds and then they keep dominating
down and then boom 45 seconds it comes
right back they own it again and you
really can't come back so I don't want
to say this fixes everything cuz I
haven't tested it yet but I'm dying I
got to get back in competitive and
really see if the 120 seconds respawn
heavy ammo thing really affects the
gameplay I mean I think it I like the
thought process that they're doing
behind it because I do feel competitive
it was you know it was definitely a
snowball effect big time with heavy ammo
yeah I mean trials had it like literally
in one round in destiny one so it wasn't
even as big of a factor but yes as
you're saying it's like if one team gets
it and especially in competitive there's
so much more like coordinated holding it
down like if they can hold it you're
screwed I mean I see that sometimes even
in QuickPlay matches if a team can sit
there and kind of control it you're
basically done anyway so much less when
competitive when it's already extra
sweaty so you have to have enough time
to maybe get some kills or have somebody
give a super go through a clearing
rotation kind of move people are on the
map so people don't farm the heavy the
whole time so I mean this is positive
for me survival as a whole 15 seconds
different which seems odd but well yeah
for the no I wrote no I was gonna say
four rotators showdown and
timers Davis initial timer stay the same
increase heavy spawn for is 60 seconds
now rumble is double as well and an ammo
count like if you actually I don't know
Rumble if you could rumbles gonna be
slower I don't play it that much but I
could picture like 60 seconds you pick
it up hang by the heavy maybe stay close
got a machine gun you got a DC man I'm
like Bam Bam Bam there's a GILF and a
man there's a kill if you could wait
long enough and then maybe hold a super
you could probably double double tap a
heavy box and Rumble and you're just
gonna win like you can't compete so that
feels better so and reduced heavy ammo
crate heavy heavy crate ammo for machine
guns words are hard I love my machine
gun so that one's a little bit of a hurt
but I still picked one up and I had 35
I'm like that's still plenty I can still
get like 4 kills with that thing if I'm
good and I just can't like spray forever
from range with it so I'm trying to
bring it in check so you know red ryx
broadsword quests basically yeah they
fix the Valerie set rings will now look
at previous season accomplishments as
well 5 Valerie sets are still required
during a single season but say if I get
them in this season and then I move on
to the next step or something it's gonna
keep it so if you want to grind out your
5 you can do that and then a Lily's
count for whatever you get there which
is nice yeah like that that's a nice
change because at the end of the day you
know you don't want to penalize the
player who's going through these resets
and then the new season start and you
bring them all the way back down on it
tomorrow lasting so let that go I like
that for Reggie I think that like regex
is really that great anyway right now so
you know there's see I don't see a lot
about it so like the whole I mean I I
don't know I'm slowly working through
the quest cuz I like I'm split between
those things I guess play my Titan for a
while definitely one for second came out
I switched the warlock recently just
because some of the quests I've been
working on but like I'm basically been
split between every like grinding weapon
like I'm half done on all of them
I'm not finished on any of them between
two characters which is just annoys me
even more it should be account based
just straight up those type of things
should all be account based and it's
getting really annoying all this stuff
being specific characters
Crucible ranks fix an issue that
prevented enhancement course from being
ordered winch and legend in valor and
glory ranks was fine
woe for activities this is just a bunch
of bug fixes and they talk about we're
not gonna go deep diving into those I
don't think there's too much to crazy
the module supports and ballistics logs
will go into the postmaster and the fact
that you can actually store those for a
little while that's a good thing
ballistics logs do not leave every week
you can hold up to five so that's just
quality of life that's probably the
biggest one I can think of absolutely
oh well we'll get to that in a second
but yeah it's kind of a save so let's
see we've got every much wraps up of
that patch notes guys so patch notes
over and now we got the new week and we
got a quest to talk about yes the world
yeah I was gonna say let's uh let's hear
it sir you gotta have the last word
because you have the last and you have a
gun you're correct so but I'll let you
talk about it first like your thoughts
out there you know I mean I thought it
was cool you know did you get the return
I thought the timing was good obviously
we know other games have been lurking
and had big weekends so I mean it is
very strategic go with them fool you you
know babe like there's no doubt in my
mind that they had that plan these these
companies know at least each other doing
for the most part certain levels and I
think they knew they needed to do
something like this just to kind of get
some engagement back with the base you
know so I I thought I thought the timing
was perfect right after you know I'm
saying an anthem initial weekend you
brought it out um yeah I thought the
question I mean for the most part was
done well for that we talked about this
offline he like I thought that um the
main thing was no time gate no time gate
that is definitely definitely cool so
like that I would I have liked a little
bit more Lord than just hey walk up to
the drifter to start it maybe maybe
maybe you know you know how I feel about
just walking up to a character
you know let's get a new quest you know
kind of ADA but um you know for the most
part I thought it was handled okay you
know I like to see the gun back it has
tremendous law and I'm curious now
because obviously we saw the trailer and
we saw what was at the end of the
trailer yeah let me speak and uh yeah I
heard to that oh it's not gonna be on
this is it no probably not no this will
just be the teaser but yeah there's a
there's a projectile stuck in a wall
yeah we're getting thorne at some point
it's happening it's happening so yeah
ready the horn is coming it's a fact I
don't even know what to think about that
you say you have cold sweats from the
recent snipers can you sleep it all now
I don't know man I mean one would think
I'll ask dizziness cuz he's running
around what's the what's the thorn ball
omen arc the thorn Bowl a monarch yeah
yeah alright you know I've been I've
been getting kind of wrecked by that a
little bit and um you know he's gonna
fun to use yeah I mean it's gonna be
interesting to see how they they bring
it back I mean my based on how they
handled last word I would temper
expectations for the people who want to
saw our tank temporal expectation that
is gonna be as dominant as it used to be
they're gonna do something to prevent it
from being like really obnoxious that's
just my feeling they know how much that
gun I mean that gun is up there as far
as infamy like as far as like people
despise it oh you know the two tab will
walk away so you know that was right up
there with the icebreakers and stuff I'm
happy that it's coming back nope not
that I'm saying I don't want it to come
back but uh you know I I feel based on
how they've been operating there is no
way it comes back in d1 for like well
it's it's just Freight obnoxious that
you're getting the green screen fact you
know you know you're out of the fight
the healing it's gonna require a little
bit more I'll be shocked
if they brought it back to that lab what
do you think I don't know last word I'm
trash with it and I was trash with the
before but I know the good people are
still good with it so if last words
fairly close to d1
I can imagine thorns if they're gonna
bring back thorn they can't just
completely like rip away what it does
right so it might I don't know
and still plopping that little
projectile nothing to you and you might
get some boys and damaged from it so you
think it you thinking these old school
d1 levels assault you think hey I got a
feel of my I mean uh I think so
Oh is thorn I mean that that is thorn if
you bring it back it's just a hand
cannon with a projectile it's just a
different looking it's just a high of
hand can't talk about the elephant new
room which is named of our podcast let's
be real as much as you know to hype the
hoopla last working all that like it's
good it's good it's good in PvP you know
saying but like shout that I Dizzy's
like I wonder how it can play with the
mouth easy oh we got to see you know but
it's like you're not using last word in
PvE II know it's definitely a PvP gun
straight up alright it's war you know
about the infamous accuracy issues you
know and even even you even all you on
PC even you yourself like it's a very
yeah but I'm not good with that gun I've
seen the good people shrill stroy with
that guy so the people who are who the
people who have the skills that had it
before it looks like it literally just
came right back it's like riding a bike
again and those people are good it's
almost shout-out to Holtzman he's got a
great review up on the last word right
now it's see dude he says I'm hot go
you'll be surprised there's more people
that are not good with it then you think
it's one of those things that it's you
know I'm definitely one of them it's an
acquired taste right and it's something
you do have to get used to is like then
once you ride the bike there's okay I
got the rhythm I got the timing of it
but it's not one of those just easy
pickup instant kind of a thing like
thorn was easy pickup instant kind of
thing too
you gonna burn away after that I doubt I
mean I'm surprised that you think that
they're gonna they're gonna make it like
that I'm actually surprised do you think
they're really gonna bring it back to
all of its d1 glory I'm what what just I
don't
okay it the dot at least has to be there
the green screen effect maybe not but I
mean the dot is the guns of Ferelden
ability so I don't know about the guy
guess it wasn't that forgot about the
green screen piece or the green like
poisonous effect but I mean maybe not
that but I think the dot might still
have to be there green haze is a bit
much probably because I'm I can't think
of anything else that really does that
tethers and stuff kind of make you real
a [ __ ]
I don't know cuz it's the only one like
that but I mean yeah we'll have to see
about I I do think the dot will have to
be there otherwise it's not thoughts no
doubt will be there no make no mistake
the question is if you remember towards
the end of d1 remember when thorn gotten
earthed into the ground oh yeah yeah
they like I think we're gonna get
something in the middle I don't think
we're gonna get d1 glory I don't think
we're gonna get d1 nerf all the way to
the ground
I think it'll be in the middle but I
don't think it'll be my gut tells me
it's not gonna be matter unless the only
way it'll be meta is if they add a new
property to it right if they add
something a little additional to make it
you know do something else or make it
like a high-skilled weapon way it has to
um you have to get headshots to bring it
to like d1 flow because before with d1
you had to be like um you know what you
call it like to the body you know saying
so listen forth here for tastier he said
apart and as the last word I'm gonna
when I get it I know I'm going to work
on it I'm I'm very skilled yeah see
you're the one who needs to put out a
little montage me I'm just like over
here like hey I look like I just got
born and I'm trying to use a gun for the
first time I'm I'm so bad with that gun
like one kill it was like it's not trash
last word is not sure I'm not saying I'm
just saying it's a skill weapon it's a
weapon that it's an acquired taste
weapon if you don't have a feel of it
it's not gonna it's not gonna go to the
masses the masses like to gravitate
towards something that is very
pick-up-and-play easy to use this
thing's kicking on you you using hipfire
which is not a naturally intrinsic thing
that most people do it's a different
kind of flow what gets me is the hipfire
I'm just like it is not my thing you're
eight yet yeah oh absolutely
very much my sit in the back and snipe
type person of course I made yes that
shouldn't be a shocker
yeah so for the quest how's it going sir
who doesn't have it yet still going I'm
up to the crucible I got to do to UM the
first part the first part the part with
the payback medals I'm gonna jump in
yeah mayhem do all that stuff and the
hive stuff so I'm literally like right
at that point so you know I'll knock
that out shout they dizzy I felt his
pain he got to the very final step and
you know how you got to three things you
gotta shoot him out three hives you
gotta shoot the gun out you know and he
recorded literally killing trading with
the boss and guy I was just like oh I
did that about four times and it
glitched so I got a lot of practice
yeah shot at this so yeah that was that
but um yeah I'm definitely getting it
it's no doubt and shout out to the
Bungie store with that a cool last word
shirt which it was a t-shirt not a long
sleeve but yeah man I got my pre-order
bonus so yeah that's getting done but
I'm gonna get that thing handled what
about you uh so I I can sense people's
frustration with a couple pieces yes
naming Lee the up and down of step two
seven one is go kill high of solar
damage not that bad
step two is exactly what you've been
talking about the volleyball court
nobody's gonna get aggressive and it it
will I use my brother for example cuz he
absolutely hates PvP so it's a perfect
thing for him but I don't even know if
he even wants the gun cuz it is a PvP
gun anyway it's like he may get it to
check the box but he's gonna hate the
whole process to get it mm-hm
it's just one of those things to where
it's like the going up and
like having to get a positive KP it's
like you're punished if you're not good
it just doesn't feel great cuz like my
first game I got it was like whoo I got
it to like 7% and I was like that's
gonna take a long time second game I was
stuck at 7% like I didn't budge and then
I like kind of got into the swing of
things and then it started jumping I got
like 25 I was up like 36 then I made
like a big jump of like 60 so like it
kind of got going I don't know if it
just it didn't feel something about the
progression and that percentage did not
feel like I got like a hundred kills
versus I know what's supposed to kills
and assists but still in that many games
I didn't think I had that many and maybe
I did but like there were a point where
I feel like I got like 40 kills but I
feel like a streak helped get me higher
now I can't for sure say anything and
it's probably not but it definitely
seemed to get some weird jumps in there
so streaks may help so yeah my advice
for doing it mmm yes sadly play like the
volleyball courts fight something ranged
you're comfortable with Scouts like
black scorpions fun to use pulse rifles
if you've got anything that you like in
that department I love my go figure if
you can snipe go to town because that's
gonna work pretty well the idea is you
don't want to trade so like shotgun
aping right now I mean if you're good at
it killing people go but running in and
just trading shotguns or trading Malee's
doesn't do you any good cuz I'm just
gonna do a sit at 0% or sit at the same
percent ask you a controversial last
word request question a controversial a
sort sir
be it if they believe this the last word
I need you to have last word on this um
what do you feel I've been seeing this
in the community what do you feel about
there's a huge I'd say a huge contingent
but I've been seeing a group of people
that the minute this quest was announced
PvP ah really
Bungie you know and there was there was
a second group you know that was saying
look get married and get good you know
what do you feel about that little
little civil war going on that the gun
is requiring a lot of these PV
he steps its I made it is a PvP garden
honestly using this thing in PvE is not
gonna serve you very well so the place
it belongs is PV PvP it's where the gun
is going to be used but in turn for me
to go get like the wish endure bow I
don't have to go do PvP right so they
take a gun and they make it PvE and PvP
but it's just one in it but it comes
from a quest right so that makes you do
PvP but I go do wish endure and I don't
have to go get like bow kills in PvP for
example now there may be Laura tied to
the different pieces in one shooting
guardians and stuff like that in the
lore pieces right but it's like when
some have the requirement for just PvE
and somebody's like cool and somebody's
like well I don't have to go do PvP for
this but now I do
I mean it is part of the game and
sometimes they're just trying to get you
outside of your comfort zone and I'm not
like completely one way or the other
like get good I can empathize with the
people who don't want to do PvP mm-hmm
because somebody who doesn't like that
part of it still has so much else to do
in this game but if they're going for
any bit of a completionist or anything
like that for say their PvE world
they're like a it's just it's a quest if
nothing else if they want to check the
box right then yeah it's one of those
pieces to where it'd be nice to see as
wild glad to say it in there if it's a
PvP weapon make the whole damn thing PvP
oh you really gotta piss them off well I
mean well no but I was like if you're
gonna make it like if that's what that
gun is focused towards make more of the
steps in there and make it focused or
and hey this is a PvP weapon this is
usually an its Guardian The Guardian
shooting is what this thing is part of
okay so you were like really really it
almost would be potentially that way now
if you made the PvP stuff that people
could progress on without losing I think
that would make it to a point where be
like I'm not that great in PvP but I
know I put them some time it's gonna be
there it's gonna be something I can work
towards but if somebody's not that good
and they're like hey I go in PvP I just
have a point five Katie I said a 0%
forever that sucks
yeah so at some point like I know
there's the get good but I wish it was
more if you got a kill it was 1% or
maybe even 2% and then if you lost it
would be like maybe a quarter or half up
you wouldn't lose as much as you gain so
it's you don't have to be positive to
make progress you can be a little less
good and still eventually work towards
it but if you're better yeah you'll blow
through it so it could be a longer grind
for someone but I wouldn't like because
honestly if somebody can't get a 1.0 KD
then they mate they will probably never
get this gun because they can't keep up
right no I mean you make a valid points
I don't really think you're saying
anything that's really you know out of
control I mean you know of course I lean
towards this I you know obviously I'm
biased towards PvP I do like PvP so um
you know I and obviously you know
shout-out to gaming Forte in the ditch
at the Lord it's a PvP weapon you know I
mean it definitely is you know I'm
saying so you know I was expecting to do
crucible behind it you know so I did
kind of feel away when people were like
oh yeah I'm making me have to do this
you know I'm saying kind of thing and
it's just like you know I kind of miss
all d1 with thorn and that stuff used to
take you out of your comfort zone and
make you play something that you
wouldn't normally play you know kind of
thing so I don't I don't have a problem
now what I did have a problem obviously
the play styles the obnoxious play style
people were using to try to get this
thing because they were getting so
desperate but okay fine that's you know
a product that's a byproduct of of
people starting as to get this gun I get
it but um no I actually actually liked
it and let's just be real like Bungie
know damn well you know the PvP
population 8 is high is press destiny we
have to assume that there's are some
other motivations behind them making
this quest you know a lot of PvP in it
but there's still a lot of PvE in it too
so let's not try to act like you know
it's it's completely all PvP thing but I
did I didn't have a problem with it I
was just interested I want to get your
feedback you know from what I saw on on
Twitter and social media and Reddit and
stuff like that as far as like people
either being upset one way other people
say hey you know get good get in and
stop complaining
yeah so I mean that step is gonna be the
big controversial one because it is a
point where you could play 20 games and
if you're not good you won't make
progress right and that's that's a hard
piece like that's one of those like just
reward and feel and psychological pieces
of how feedback goes in a game and if
you're working on this like new
announced quest hey this is the exotic
thing for the Annual Pass
everything's been these forges it's PvE
content and this is the one thing for
PvP which the PV people are like sweet I
finally got something but then that
other person's like hey this is part of
my annual pass and I can't get it and
that just doesn't feel great to a point
like if this is one of those things
where there are times when they do
certain things if they had an
alternative okay gotcha
or this or like or ya know get you know
go work on your percentage in PvP or go
you know say you had to get two hundred
thousand points on a nightfall
easy to do it's easier now so you could
make the threshold pretty high or do
something make it a harder task in the
PvE world but give you a you know
something like that for a good he's
sitting you only have to average a zero
point
okay I will straight up tell you that is
not now I was like I will tell you
that's not true because I went one
percent for a kill I died I went back to
zero I got a kill at 7 percent I went
back at seven to eight I got died it
went back down to seven so now assists
count but if it is literally like a kill
and a death it is still one to one does
this give you bonuses that will probably
help you get a boost but it is a if you
just go like you kill somebody and you
dive that is a net zero like you don't
get a bonus from that I tested it I was
literally zero one zero like I watched
it happen and it was killed death like
it went back to nothing seven eight nine
eight seven like I watched my numbers go
up and down I checked him like every
death I was watching it pretty close so
it was a very funny divisive thing to
commute it to bring it out but I digress
good yeah so you've got that piece which
you know we've rehash to death um but
then we've also got
mayhem for the Avenger and revenge
medals I forget what they're called
blood for blood and some other thing
yeah so those are those are easier to
get in mayhem just because there's a lot
of insanity going on people are going to
be trading Mayhem's its own animal but
without mayhem I can see that step also
taking a long time cuz those are just
generally organic things like killing
the person who killed you you might see
them but you might not why not yeah you
might save someone or as some people
said run as a pair and have somebody get
sacrificed and you kill follow
afterwards which is really sad but true
um but some of those are just like
natural metals in like and that's the
point where you are gonna spend time in
PvP and you'll eventually probably get
there but that one without mayhem
because that's this week and again we
never know if it comes back or when it
could be a while that's why if you don't
get it this week I am it's gonna be a
bit tough so now I'm on that I'm on now
but only thing is that that damn anthem
game there's gonna be a hashtag
Longpoint hashtag last word long point
yeah you're gonna crash when we're done
with this one again we're gonna keep it
tidy and nope we're we're talking yeah
but yeah so I will have to say for those
of you guys listening if you catch this
later on and hopefully they will fix it
later the last step in this quest has
some cool mechanics to it and wild glad
I will get to your comment a second I
just got to read it but if you die at
certain points in the last stage of this
quest line like the last quest when
you're doing this thing the conversation
I have like eight glitched like I did
all the pieces correctly I shot all the
things I needed to shoot couldn't finish
it
mmm I exited the activity it sent me it
was back in the tangled Shore standing
in front of the light quest mission flag
started up again did it again still
didn't count finally went back to orbit
went back through died once so then it
was glitched so I had to go back to
orbit all the way again
so I did it four times that wasn't cool
like the check points do not work in
that one to mine I mean maybe it's
different for other people or something
was happened and they're saying maybe
walk really slow on certain parts but
yeah there's certain text that changes
as you go through it's like find this
guy you know follow him and then kill
him and that's like if the text doesn't
change you're pretty much locked and you
can do about it and that really kind of
sucked
oh yeah it's kind of a cool quest there
was no kind time gate which is cool
the final mechanic was kind of fun but I
will say like when you have me grind
stuff out and I have to do 15 lost
sectors yeah that's long like three
public events and waiting for those to
show it and I wish it wasn't like three
specific public events because I could
like I wouldn't grinded like I don't
know ten of the lost sector on Titan
which I can do quickly like I can run in
there shoot a few ads wait for the over
to pop his face out blow them away with
something sleeper three times or chaos
reach or whatever and then I can keep
grinding it over and over and eventually
it's gonna show up but waiting on a
specific public event like public events
just on a location would be even like a
better option yeah I know they need ort
I know they need to be hive but man some
of that stuff just is a drag when you're
waiting on those but 15 loss sectors
that ogre and me have a friendship now
so love/hate thing just there because
that's the quickest one to do like Titan
like because I will grind up the lost
sector on what am I thinking core
terminus I won't grind that one out for
my forged weapons because I do all the
pulse rifle stuff in there but if you
just need to go kill a boss the big news
the way to go the big ogre just big
target big face shoot a minute go but
fifteen times
yeah that's long that's too much yeah
that's the last word quest overall kind
of fun question long in a couple parts
and some things that are your control
but if you stick with it stay
conservative on the PvP front hopefully
you guys have some luck I just know a
lot of people struggle with it yeah now
this this I got to talk about because
there's a special place in my heart
right here
the whisper quest is available every day
from any lost lost away such public
event oh you heard it here first
you bought this has no excuse to help me
not get my catalyst now you heard it
here first thank you record he's own
wreck he's gotta help me get my catalyst
now oh hey no excuses I can do it I can
do it I need to brush up um but yeah I
love this quest you guys half of my
channel probably knows me from this
video alone what it's open it's all the
time now like this is I think the final
thing I have had more comments on my
video and you cannot put annotations on
videos anymore on YouTube so I can't
like put something on the beginning
saying hey this is only act from this
point I have to put in the comments and
most people don't read those so I had
more questions
I've killed these taken bosses like 15
times and cake at the portal to spawn
I'm like it's only up up on the weekends
and I try and reply to everybody but man
I'm glad to see this back yes good all
the time always no reason to grind at
some point I just need to be like um
whisper carries on PC just like tick and
I can go let's go and all you're doing
is waiting for a public event in LA so
ASIS you might have to wait for like one
or two rotations it's not gonna be as
bad
let's get caucus catalyst man let's do
it we got you um I don't know like let
me know your thoughts on the whisper
mission when you've run through it - you
like it enjoy it any ups and downs like
what do you think one of the greatest
secrets in history of a Bungie I mean
this is this is up there this is one of
the shining moments so yeah they see it
you know do it now as a any possibility
everyday as a public event it's like
it's really cool so I'm all about it you
know at the end of the day you know it's
one of those things that everyone should
experience it if you haven't you need to
and it was interesting I was actually
surprised okay this is this is
interested yeah I had no idea this was
coming I saw the tweet none like didn't
see this coming at all you know and um
hey it's again one of the coolest pieces
of content shouted dizzy like don't get
him as careless cog never helped me get
my sleeper catalyst haha then we go get
that catalyst because that's the whole
reason why I'm hyped because now
I feel confident I can get my sleeper
catalyst at my own pace because part of
getting the sleeper catalyst involves
you already having the whisper catalyst
so yeah it's got to go down now man so
all you hear of the sleeper catalyst is
that catalyst
yes it's Yodas how is that wait no that
I mean sleeper catalyst was out before
Whisperer existed how's that even his
aren't tied together his art works when
you get the sleeper catalyst mmm you've
got to have those chests in there
those arm what is it the yellow things
the the would you shoot him but why am i
blinking from faulty glass the things
Oracle's Oracle's you gotta have that
certain parts done and you gotta have
the chest that's part of completing you
don't have to have the whisper catalyst
but you you have to be in the part as
part of completing the the sleeper
catalyst yeah that one I think sinister
pull me I was like really they pick
they're making that time he's like yeah
the sleeper catalyst is long steps and
that's one and another one is like you
have to have all three eye closed
weapons you know and then you gotta get
kills with them it is insane all the
stuff you have to do first why is that
one so ridiculous and I have like just
get kills with another weapon I'm like
they really don't want you guys there
and then sleeper catalyst yeah and you
know how I feel about sleep asleep is
always like one of my little favorites
so it's something that it's been itching
me the only shot the Forte he's one of
the few that have it that had it on
console so it's like I need to get that
gun the completionist in me if I love
that weapon is burning my soul that I do
not have that's done so whispered needs
to be done ahead of time so yeah but
whispers a lot of fun if you guys are on
PC hit me up sometimes I think I got
like six PC friend requests from this
little update so people are probably
gonna be seen me random game messages
whisper hello knocking on the door so oh
I guess I'm gonna have to polish up my
chops cuz that video is a little old I
got to see if I still got it
so cause like riding a bike man you know
now it's like I can run multiple people
through there but yeah just a full solo
carry if somebody's like struggling like
yeah you could you jump for like 20
minutes back there I'll go take care of
this like that that might take a little
practice so we'll see
no doubt oh but we are getting into
season six coming not that far away can
you believe that no it's not one season
of The Drifter it's it's I a lot of
question of what we're gonna do in
season the drifter but yeah
mm-hmm they have some changes coming for
plans
Clank plans clients these past two
seasons we've tried some new things
during that time we've gathered hard
hard data heard a ton of feedback thanks
and now that we're going to talk about
what's next so when they're talking
about game designs they said it's a good
eyes they want to have goals all the
stuff they do have goals generally you
know big high points you know I am the
sky vision so they wanted to create
stronger claims where players can make
new friends and destiny and stronger
incentives for clients to play together
all right now the incentives are still
not that great I'm not saying this is
better
just Midge but still not amazing clans
like honestly like the incentives in
game they're either gonna be like game
breaking so elms can't make it too good
but like they do kind of need to give a
little more incentive which is a good
thing but what they're gonna be doing
for season six they're returning to the
destiny to launch system for gaining
clay and exp go play activities in the
game and you will earn clan exp can I
just like thank you seriously
daily bounties are gone all every daily
bounty was I think pyro said it once
he's like I got like 70 daily bounties
for the whole week on all the characters
he's like I think there's four they're
not crucible or gambit like if there
were more variety and those sometimes it
wouldn't been done quite as bad but and
they were always crucible or gambit if
you want to go play PV stuff you're like
well guess I'm not doing those today
yeah so just playing will give you the
XP they're now three weekly bounties
that require playing together with clan
baits there were three so 1 will be PvE
there will be one PDE
raid and PvP weekly bounty from Hawthorn
that's pretty cool they were they reward
legendary gear and a big chunk of
cleaning XP so like even if you just do
one weekly bound you doing PvE stuff or
you run a raid with some clan mates
that's pretty cool so
and then as your clan level as your
claim levels its banner the rewards grow
neva this is the best rewards I've ever
seen and they finally made something
actually as decent at rank three you
earn mod components when completing a
weekly bounty well at rank four you earn
enhancement cores when completing a
weekly ball whoa
well that's big yeah and then at rank
six your clan will unlock a fourth
weekly bounty so as you rank up you'll
get a mod for that point once he hit
rank three for doing a weekly and then
if you do a PvE let's say you'd be like
I'm gonna go grind some strikes and then
I'm gonna go do a couple crucible
matches that could be like 2 mod
components into enhancement course just
by playing so there's a lot they're
putting more sources for those in there
which is good and those are things
people are actually gonna use
so pretty much decent changes here
better than at least like Oh get some
more glimmer here or an extra from a pub
like those who are I'm sorry but yeah
those were not not really incentive to
do anything let's just keep it real
mm-hmm this is good this is good I like
this this this is what I'm talking my
man again more sources for my components
instead of just locked to a de you know
enhancement course not it's just as more
sources instead of you know hoping that
we had what was it the dawning you know
means in spider you know you want you
want that kind of stuff you want that
incentive so I definitely like this
direction this is really cool just doing
stuff is going to get you XP as well
like they'd taken it back to just plain
you know so that's just that's better
that's how all that's and that's like
that type of model is what they should
do for faction rallies like just doing
all these different activities not you
know depositing 6000 tokens in whoo I'm
a vending machine I mean that's what it
feels like just doing content like hey
if we do a crucible match and we win
then we get a boost or something like
that or if you know my team does a raid
you get like 200 points and crucible
matches worth 10 a win is like 25 and
just like have everything do things and
have just how people play the game and
see where everybody lies like if the
crazy Raiders all pick you know somebody
doing raid carries all week picks like
that orbit that's a lot of weight if
they're finishing them out so I don't
know that that could be a thing they
could use if they just have that
generally XP it'd be nice to see that
come back
but we cannot skip perk tier 5 this is
big get it so epic reads crucible and
strike catalysts have play shoutout to
polit I see the man has been waiting for
this
hey callous fiend uh I mean but when
they dropped I mean how much of a grind
did that add to the game when they
dropped him a more might how cool was
all that that was cool
fairy who would have wore my so
underrated I really love a lot of stuff
they added it in catalyst added a whole
level of minutia and things to chase and
it made a difference it really made it
made a certain exact feel brand new like
it really did so this is good to see so
striking crucible catalysts have an
increased drop rate when playing with
clan mates
that's tier 5 for those of you who
haven't found all the catalysts you'll
be able to have a better chance of
finding the ones you're missing if you
already have them all we plan to release
a few more from our year 1 Reserve
during season of The Drifter they won't
be released day 1 but keep your eyes on
patch notes for availability Hey good
stuff man I'm about this I'm up
seriously now do here's the question do
you think they a lot day they unlock
stuff that was for example like the
graviton Lance catalyst and the SunShot
cap that will double previously like
those have to be there they said those
were gonna be there months ago right so
you think those are gonna be part of
that loophole I hope so
like those maybe something like Soros
maybe hardlight I mean there's just some
some basic year ones that do not have
catalysts the beat'em just straight away
so those type of the ones are the ones I
hope get in there I mean if it strikes
and that's that would be a reason to
grind out strikes for a change because
right now there's not much of one but
like I hope it's not just like standard
strikes I mean it'd be nice if some of
these were you know maybe I mean story
missions would be kind of a grind but at
least it would be an incentive but like
if it strikes make sure night falls
count too or if you go pick you know
like a shadows from the map or something
just if they limit it too much it's
still annoying but it's just nice to see
more and my other question as many
people have said and I think tasks
had an awesome idea for this to the
armor-like yes but working or enhancing
or whatever you want to call it to all
of our our exotic armor like it's not
there it's like the other side of my the
Isle is completely missing these
catalyst benefits and I'm like there's
so much they could do with that and
maybe it's just like development time
and balancing and they're waiting for d3
and other things are on the table but
man the exotic armor there's there's a
bit a bit lacking right there yeah
I agree I agree dad that dad is long
overdue you know we've been beating that
drum for the longest yeah for forever Oh
agreed new exotic armor balancing much
less the catalyst never got that yeah
yeah balancing and catalyst to do at
some point but yeah this is good to see
man I want to see more these catalysts
drop out and if they're gonna be doing
that and tied the clamps I'm all for it
yep yep cleaning house so this is just a
good thing going into season 6 for each
season for second change things we have
all these bounties that we do bounties
came back which is big
well bounties are something you can hold
on to and there's certain ones that give
you powerful gear there's also keys in
the last trade which they didn't account
for people having stacks of those things
and being able open like six chests and
they never run being able to like grind
out raids if they've got it down to a
science
- really really max out their play level
well they're gonna fix that
so going into season the drifter etheral
keys from the last of trade will have a
max stack of five so you get five drops
you can do one run open five chests and
then you're back on normal play field
iron banner bounties which are seven
bounties which are worth a buttload of
gear will not carry over either and will
expire so no carrying those forward as
well yes please thank you so I mean
those are probably the two biggest
offenders you could probably save up cuz
I know you could save up like I could
save powerful gear if I did all six of
the ascendant challenges and started not
turning them in I know I've got those
saved so I don't know if they're gonna
change stuff like that because
technically HSN in Bali is tied to its
own week so I've helped like three of
them
like three of them on the same character
before which is weird but you can so
there's certain ones you can still keep
and honestly I just want all-powerful
bounties to be gone like all powerful
gear bounties from the previous season
either need to link to that season so
it's gonna give you a max of 650 or just
go away either way just you know clean
out your boundaries get a clean slate
you're good to go so this is a good
thing so going into the next season
everybody's on the same playing field
the grinders and the hoarders don't have
all this you know extra stuff to go in
the new season so this is just a
positive thing yeah I agree I agree this
is really good and again the hoarders
and this to me you know how I feel about
raids and day one and I'm just tired of
these you know dudes with these unfair
advantages because they just held on all
their iron banner bellies and these
other stuff just to milk the system so
make that you know make the playing
field even you know come launch day so
people can actually compete for world's
first yeah just a fair race cuz there's
some people like I think it was it was
it not last wish but I mean season
though the forge that was a joke people
were too high so I mean they didn't have
the if it would have been normal within
three days people grinding out the
forward just people I'd been like 6:15
6:20 not like 650 before the raid came
out in three days it was do it yeah
right ready for score just go to 650
yeah they've really ready so it's
ridiculous like kid can the common man
have a chance at the jacket okay I mean
I'm probably never getting of the jacket
I'm not worried about that but a little
more levelness to everybody last wish
was honestly one of the cooler ones I
mean yeah an 18-hour grind is insane
but most people were still just I mean
even with a lot of grinding and stuff
we're pretty capped towards that 550 ish
range 560 like that's about as high as
you get and that made that thing rough
and that's I was okay with that so but
that pretty much wraps up the table so
whisper is a grind but wild glad said it
pretty well too I just wanted to say
he's like he may not like PvP he may not
even been that great at it but actually
having to go into PvP
and just get outside of your comfort
zone some of you may not like it but if
you sit there and play a little while
you may get a little better and it may
give you incentive to go check it out
every soft and so sometimes it's just
Bungie taking their content actually
saying hey we still at PvP in here come
check it out for a little while and just
you know give you an incentive play it
so if you want the gun I'm gonna have to
play it a little bit so sometimes I
think that's okay it's just sometimes
the progress or and you know an option
would be good but you know it's one of
those that I think in the grand scheme
of things is not all that bad once I
kind of got into the mix it got better
and better but I know there's some
people that will be frustrated just try
and play cautious and safe and that's my
main advice
gonna be it's like you go ahead I'll be
right behind you as in a hundred yards
behind you looking down my scope
watching they run around the corner oh
he didn't make it well I'm just gonna
see if it okay I got that guy BAM
there you go yeah you can you can just
talk to somebody and if you've got the
gun already you get to be the bait and
I'm gonna send you out there when your
head explodes I know where they're
coming from cool shego teamwork up
teamwork makes the dream work
you're just sacrificing eventually get
some benefits who knows so um so it
shattered thrown is this weekend's if
you haven't done that one could be tied
to your bounties but I have to try and
squeeze shattered thrown in with this
yes that anthem whoa let's get it let's
get to it
VIP demo was the past weekend open demo
starts in literally an hour yes it is
open to everybody they patched it
actually we have to see that I did that
I mean I downloaded a patch so I was
like I know I don't load it something so
I update it may not be perfect and it's
not gonna be the final game state it's
gonna be more just an updated demo right
but more stability and things like that
should be there but it's yeah I know
I've been talking for a while so anthem
demo I know you got to play it let's
hear it what do you think yes um
fantastic I mean what once you got in
yeah you know I we put the quotes up
once you were able to get in and yeah it
got past all stuff it's it's really
something different
yeah I told you guys before I had played
the Alpha you know the only difference
was that in the Alpha there was more of
a tutorial whereas the demo that was
last week
it was kind of kind of just kind of
throw you in the mix into the arm no to
things so I will say this man you know
graphically this thing is really special
the flight ah really special and then
the key for me is each javelin is so
unique they do not play the same you
know if you arm shout out to Forte it's
great when you can play it it is oh yeah
so it's like you know Ranger you know
that's that's Iron Man you know jack of
all trades you know kind of a kind of a
character you know the Colossus
obviously your prototypical tank you
know I didn't get a chance to touch
Colossus that that demo but I did I'll
really focus on storm and interceptor
and storm was something I gravitated
toward at first making that was what I
want to play and it definitely revolves
you know being able on getting a lot of
props and stuff like that and um you
know it played different than what I
thought I had to get used to it
surprisingly interceptor played really
well for me and I didn't think I would
like that kind of accountable but the
movement I mean it literally felt like
interceptor was moving at 60 frames per
second and the other characters weren't
like that's how good intersects fluid
fast you know combo based
maneuverability you know so again the
thing that they got going from plays
well graphically well you know arm
didn't get a chance to really get
destroy the stronghold stuff done I was
really messing around a lot of free play
stuff cuz I I was just so enamored by
the movement ain't like there's nothing
better than meeting just like jumping up
in the air doing a standalone hover you
know shooting in media coming down with
a mainly going back up in the air flying
up to the damn stratosphere like the
flight in this game is so well done like
so I've never any controls again if
you're using controller okay it was a it
felt really good now how are people say
you know with with mouse and keyboard
it's a little difficult it's not as
smooth you're doing it on PC but if you
use a controller or a console or PC
it really feels good it's so intuitive
so that's the biggest surprise and then
um you know they did the prey in a
cooperative play in the team work and
then messing around the frames and the
customization so overall strong
foundation I'm very excited for this
demo that's about to go up this weekend
hopefully they fix the server issues
they have all I've done but what about
you man you I know you was playing a lot
you and stone were playing a lot you
know what's your overall feel of anthem
thus far so I mean there's no question
they had server issues that was a thing
but honestly and that's why I said in my
little intro video about my thoughts
about it their transparency as
developers on Twitter if you follow in
Irving and Michael gamble and some of
those guys out there they had like three
different blog updates over the weekends
demo they were tweeting the whole time
they were working on it I can tell you
there's some IT guys which you can
probably empathize with because they
probably didn't sleep so they worked
their butt off so I definitely can say
some people maybe like it CAAT AATA
Bioware wants to make this a thing and
the people leading it I said I literally
tweeted directly to Ben Irving and just
said you have answered more questions
then I have seen one producer or anyone
involved in a game answer in my life
I agree like if you look at his Twitter
it's like every five minutes he's
literally he must be just sitting there
me like wait for it all right sighs the
question in her okay what's next and he
just goes like that must be his job now
it is insane how many things he has
answered and that type of transparency
and questions and asking and it's like
not these around about answers it's
either yes or no or we're doing this or
it's something I mean if they don't have
a plan they'll say it's like maybe in
the future it's something we're
considering or whatever but a lot of
just like consistent communication and
it's been that communication going into
the demo gave me more faith that even I
know the connection issues weren't there
that I have at least an idea of what how
the passion they have for the game yeah
absolutely
absolutely I'm glad you said that
because you know obviously the elephant
in the room obviously is EA's and
everyone feels how they feel about EA I
get that but here's the deal you know
like you said I haven't seen the level
of transparency between devs like this
like they are literally telling you for
Batum what's happen
what's going on answering every question
like I don't know what else more you
want to do if you still feel a way about
ei fine take your issues out with ei you
don't want to do you didn't want to do
the what is it the UM the VIP pre-order
fine yeah and it's free there's no
excuses everybody you don't have to have
anything just check out the game cuz I'm
telling you right now when you check out
the game and you feel it and you you you
your opinions might change that's all
I'm saying anyone on the fence there's
really no excuse for you not to try this
game this weekend so hopefully like I
said the server issues you know a little
bit better it may be get it may get hit
harder because now this is open up to a
bigger pool this is everybody so but
what more do you want he right but
they're testing it to me it's the
ultimate sign of confidence who's doing
that right who's letting you just go
into their game what is it about a week
or two weeks before release Dan he was
out on 20 seconds I got three weeks him
so it's like I love what they're doing
you know I know like I said the
microtransactions telling people get a
little crazy but again that's all
cosmetic you know I'm not gonna go crazy
about that I'm not seeing pay2win stuff
you know and that was being transparent
as long as I have those things I have no
issue so I advise people give the game a
shot and if you get in let me know what
you think yeah like that's the thing for
me is they have confirmed multiple times
that because that the microtransactions
are cosmetic only now you can be up in
arms about an iron banner emote for $10
it does not affect your game place so
make a decision and if you're like hey
you know what I spend 60 bucks on this
game but this iron banner emote fits my
persona so well I'm a lord of the round
table
I have to have it like and that's one of
those you like you know if I've got the
money and I'm gonna make that decision
I support Bungie I'm gonna spay this ten
bucks fine make that call but no way
does anything ever in ever earth change
your gameplay at all and this is the
same thing here people are freaking out
saying hey it's 20 bucks or it's gonna
be 20 bucks for this skin pack do you
have any idea how much you can customize
in this damn game it is insane
wait you can do so much not country oh
but my understanding is that prices that
people were seeing earlier in Santa
we're not final I believe up right I
thought Bob Bioware got in front of that
yeah they're like they're placeholders
they're still tweaking that stuff all
the time
and you can earn in-game currency to buy
it eventually anyway you literally don't
have to just like I have like so much
bright like bright does now doesn't
matter I can buy almost all of that
stuff same thing
you're going to be like getting an
option to be like hey if I just play the
game and I'm in max the crap out of my
stuff and I'm play for a long time I
might eventually get that skin pack and
now if I want every skin pack in the
whole tate whole game it was probably
gonna take a minute but if you want to
spend you know maybe 10 bucks you've
been there like man I put like 200 hours
in this game this one skin is there I
really want to get it but it might be a
grind weed spy it and that's your choice
but like the whole microtransaction
thing they're just cosmetics guys let
them go there's not they're not gonna
let you buy any gameplay changing things
and they've made it very very clear so I
think all in all that that piece is a
good start as you said the communication
has been huge and then all I have to say
is jump up in the air and hit flight and
that's all you have to do literally as
soon as you get as soon as you jump in
your javelin you jump up in the air and
you hit a flight and you start feeling
like I'm Iron Man you're like I'm done
I'm in this I'm I'm it's the the
animations the wave the javelins feel
and I'll get to the distinction of the
classes in a little bit but just like
the ease of jumping in the air and
flying around you know flying is good
waters trip was trash which they're
working on and there's some sensitivity
issues there when you and when you're in
the water you really have to move slow
but flying around feels so good I mean
it's exactly what you'd expect like I'm
gonna make I jump I fly and I go this
direction it's like and it does it like
that's easier said than done so though
they absolutely crush the flight of each
of the classes and speaking of the
classes this is a difference from
destiny that for me is big
the Colossus vs. the Interceptor are
about as far apart as you can get
tighten in the hunter in destiny do not
feel that far apart they do but they
don't right like I mean if I go fold
you know resilience or full mobility and
you're gonna have some tweaks and stuff
but they don't have a feel the Colossus
is a completely different beast that's
literally like half of the Interceptor
or less like or more the Colossus is
this big honking tank you'll and it
sounds like thunder when you hit the
ground you're slow to get going you're a
little more deliberate on all your
actions you have a physical shield in
front of you which is hilarious by the
way yeah and then the Interceptor is
literally what I would consider a robot
ninja fling in out quick jump around I'm
pretty sure I was gonna make people
throw up on my stream just by motion
sickness because I was cuz on mousing
keyboard like I play mouse in keyboard
not control and second I got a feel for
it so I just uncomfortable with that
some people aren't as big of a fan and
say controller is good but the things I
can do on that interceptor like jump in
the air and I can move my mouse do a
quick 180 and just all my unfilled so
good it feels so good you know PC good
lord
good luck oh it looks so good
no question that frostbite engine looks
amazing there's no doubt no doubt listen
I played our Xbox first and it was fine
it was solid it was cool but I jumped
over to PC and there was no frame pacing
issues and that 60 frames
oh this thing yeah definitely a
graphical showcase there's no doubt
about it
this thing really really looks good
mm-hmm yeah so I mean you've got the
Interceptor which is like an endo very
neat Minda ninja a very melee based very
cool in and out abilities and each one
has their own pieces like my abilities
are all there melee based I don't have
too much in the way of like you know
projectiles or anything
the Colossus has a flamethrower you're a
walking tank with a shield you have a
little orb on your back the cast
lightning around you you get into the
storm
that's your caster I mean picture it
literally has a cape and picture that's
your cloth armor class that's your mage
that's your wizard they're squishy
they're your glass cannon they put out
so much damage in combos oh my god like
I finally got to
touch the storm and I was like all right
this is insane and that's the other
thing you just say and that's the thing
that also separates anthem know the
combo system just that different classes
working together you know saying
utilizing the strengths you know of a
colossus or you know the storms in the
background in the air you know it's so
many things and I think they they have
that synergy thing now you know now I
got something they're picking on LA you
know that I was like it's not perfect
but they still two enemies I don't know
how I feel all the way about the enemies
just yet and the way they respawn is
little weird you know my main gripe
right now if I really got a nitpick is I
don't know how I feel about not being
able to get into Luke instantly and
everything revolving around going back
to for Tarsus and going back to the
forge kind of deal you know I don't know
how I feel about that all the way is it
something that's gonna make me to turn
me from playing a game no probably not
yeah it's just one of those things like
you know I would probably like that to
be able to do that in game but you know
again it's still a lot of promise man
still a lot of stuff that did you do
stronghold Oh many times over yeah like
yeah I beat it so many times over that
weekend so the stronghold is cool
stronghold I would at best reference is
gonna be like a strike kind of how it
feels there's so many Me's you get to a
middle point you have kind of a mechanic
place to defend for a little while
work through farther and then you're
gonna have a boss like I mean that's the
general rundown it's kind of like a
strike now the the boss like that that
boss design of that giant nasty spider
but man that game looks good it's ugly
as hell but I mean it looks good but man
it's gross but I definitely will say
that dude stepped on my head a few times
as an interceptor so that didn't feel
great but I did learn something about
don't don't disregard the Ranger it may
be and I put my first video about like
meteor javelins so you guys can check
that out there's like 30 minutes of
gameplay about it the Ranger is the
jack-of-all-trades and it may be
master of none yet I can tell you that
thing is never not gonna be functional
in a fight the Interceptor on that boss
fight
I was ad clearing mmm-hmm or I was
tagging enemies or I was using a sniper
but my melee on that boss is next and
not not gonna do much like that is not
your purpose like solo class is an
interceptor I mean if you were trying to
like solo something and work on a boss
it's going to be difficult because
that's not what you're built for you are
meant to be in there next to it and
unfortunately seemingly they took that
one from destiny big bosses apparently
smash the ground so yep
but the Ranger projectiles combos has
access to every damage type ice fire
lightning and acid you can clear a lot
of ads if you need to you still have
some mobility and agility you can take a
few shots and not be completely squishy
like the Ranger is the one where it's
gonna be you're always gonna have
something to do and I think people are
like I don't know the Ranger you know
it's like it's not as good or you know
the storms better I was like there are
times when the storms in there in the
mix but I guarantee if you fall on the
ground and a couple enemies overrun you
as the storm you're about to die almost
instantly
it was hard difficulty like that shield
is gone you take like one sniper shot
you look cool none so yeah that that
Ranger is gonna have some really good
function to it and honestly like the
dream team for me would be one of each
absolutely yeah absolutely right
range is just so versatile like it's
just it really can do everything and
shop the fourth day he actually
disagrees with me he actually loves the
fact that you can't um go into the menus
and kind of stuff cuz he I guess he
wants people to focus it you know on
actually just playing and instead of
doing compare weapons and gear stats in
the middle of a race I get it it's just
like I don't know what I mean in a loop
based game you know I don't know I kind
of I don't know you see I don't know how
I feel about that like if I tried
something you be the boss or something
and you blue traps and I can't know what
it is you know they all like you just
locked into your loadout for the entire
thing it's just an adjustment again I'm
not like oh this is the worst thing ever
but I just got to get used to it right
now
don't know how I feel about that right
now yeah I mean there are some benefits
being able to change like on the fly um
and destiny you really can't change on
the fly be like hey I need to change am
i super in the middle of this here like
you're gonna be stuck so I mean I would
trust me when I was going through
recording my footage for all those
things going like pick two abilities
record the footage head back to fort
Tarsus and you know those loading times
was like so I mean it was a struggle for
that type of thing for sure but their
idea behind that and again like I've got
to see how it feels in time but they're
at least idea behind it as they don't
want you checking loot like it's not
sticking up with your team like you're
just in the mix using your abilities
when you get to the end you can go check
out and change stuff so I was like in
theory it makes sense but for me there
are times like if I get a new thing and
I'm like I summon that something drops
like I level master work or legendary
crazy drop and it's like a new thing and
I want to put it on like maybe I would
survive better but if you're starting an
activity you're probably able to finish
it so I don't know I mean it's not like
there's gonna be a raid where you work
your way through you get a drop and be
like oh this one helped me level up it's
like no you're gonna give as hard as you
can get go back out and then maybe try
it again
mmm and I'm as I was saying it's like
recording the footage believe me I would
have paid an arm and a leg to be able to
switch that stuff out just staying in
there that would have helped me so much
blood having your team stay with you
nobody's like stuck looking in their
inventory it's not even a worry
everybody just in the game playing and I
think that immersion in the game not
worrying you're just like hey I've got
these two abilities couple guns and just
straight up in the mix the whole time
it's you not you're not stuck buried in
that for so long and then if you are in
your own fort Tarsus nobody else is
waiting on you and it's they do have a
little more separation which just keeps
the gameplay more focused which has some
benefits that probably are a little
subtler than will probably be known for
now but I think that could do very well
so we got this weekend is gonna kick off
and in about 30 minutes
probably 40 minutes here we go sir and
that at the same time so once again I
will be delayed I'll get my serve video
up they don't check out anthem gotta see
I got to see the the day the desert
drops an exotic for something else for
like for a forsaken people are gonna
lose their mind and I got to be there
for that at least while I can let's see
we'll see but uh we got something else
going on what what I don't I was gonna
say I don't know trying to think if
there's anything else for all I do want
to talk about the gear real quick just
drops enjoy the perks and everything's
work so your focus and destiny is so
much on your wet like a lot on your
weapons and even like Bungie puts the
catalyst on the weapons first before the
armor because you live and breathe for
your weapons that is honestly one of
those pieces that like Bungie does so
well like gameplay gunplay in destiny
feels amazing I don't think many people
are gonna argue that it feels great
like all the guns that you need they
feel good you get really attached to it
all I got my blast furnace with my
perfect roll like I've had my go figure
since I got the thing in forsake and I
just love that thing and I've brought it
with me the whole way mmm
anthem is very very different mmm anthem
is all abouts anthem is like a Diablo
it's your loot drops it's getting that
next different thing nothing carries
forward you don't level anything up so
if you have a really good roll some
point it might get replaced with
something better but the thing is if I
get a better Devils for example if I get
a marksman rifle of called anvil it's
always going to shoot the same yep so
you're not even gonna have different
roles for like hey appended magazine now
you might have some random stuff like a
painted magazine or clip size and those
are just gonna be like little perks that
can roll but I'm not gonna have a
different scope I'm not gonna have you
know the perks of like dragon fly or
anything like that on weapons weapons
are gonna be more of a secondary feel
right and your abilities which recharge
much much faster than destiny on the
other side I have my grenade up every
eight seconds or 10 like it's up all the
time same with your other abilities like
whichever two you have are up more
frequently when the strange thing is
like in this lake even in Diablo your
abilities are somewhat intrinsic to your
character you level up you unlock them
and things like that are just part of
your character even World of Warcraft
their skills you unlock
they're in this game your abilities are
also part of the drops like you're gonna
have legendary just like you have an
exotic weapon you're gonna have an
exotic ability drop now it's still gonna
be like a seeking missile for the Ranger
for example but that is gonna be like
the way you level that thing up is
getting a new version of that which has
some ups and downs as well sometimes
you're gonna be like hey I love this
build of God I've got the flamethrower
on the Colossus and then I've got this
lightning orb on the back I'm self
comboing like all the time well I got a
new masterwork and it's a completely
different thing yeah but it's a
masterwork it's awesome
well I use this I have to change my
build but then you are actually gonna
change your build which means you
actually might change your play style
because you have other stuff dropping so
like there's so much tied to your
abilities and that's what you're gonna
live and die by but as they're based on
drops your play style may change if you
just get a whole new drop which is kind
of crazy like what do you think about
that whole system the gear the drops
like what are your thoughts on just the
way the whole build of each javelin
works who this listen at the end of the
day this is what I keep trying to tell
people when I see online oh it's just
another destiny no it's not just because
something shares the same genre space it
doesn't does it mean it's going to play
the same this game does not play the
same I definitely get that vibe of
Diablo I definitely get that vibe again
it's not gun based like that it's more
ability based it's more you know said so
all the things you're saying like I
already kind of had that feeling this is
where it was going right and this is
cool this is a different crowd this is a
different demographic that's gonna
really enjoy and it's gonna be destiny
people that love this - you know I mean
I think for me forget all the other you
know minutia with that I just want to
see now the story aspect you know how
obviously I don't that would run and get
that this weekend but um you know when
the full game like how is that in and
how invested all week cuz the vibe I'm
getting it this is all for you destiny
fans who you know they trying to figure
out where and like to me I look at them
is that like sexy side piece you that
it's a PC does they like something you
just want to just play have fun with
your boys for play
is you know it looks great it's that
Diablo feel you can come back to it
and I to be honest like I think you can
coexist because at the end of the day
destiny is the gun play game right it's
it's it's you know what's did what
archetype wouldn't matter what you know
gun gun gun gun gun you know yeah we got
abilities no doubt whereas I think
anthem is completely different and it
also has a little bit more teamwork
involved with the classes and stuff like
that they really play different and I
think again the Diablo fans are gonna
like this the warframe fans are gonna
like this
you don't mean it's a different audience
it's a different and it's doing
something different so as far as the
drops you know it's more subtle exotic I
use I guess more Diablo more demands
with gun drops anthem is armour guns and
abilities yeah I would agree with that
you shout out the meds he's like bootleg
warframe it it's not bootlegging
warframes because they but it is I will
say it is closer I will say well I agree
with sundown it is closer to one frame
than it is desta it's not destiny
that's a fact like it's not so yeah all
that stuff it's not that but I'm not I'm
enjoying it man I really am I'm looking
forward to see where they go in the key
to me there's gonna be consistent
content drops have to do that how the
story gonna play out and it looks like
right now alive I'll check that we gotta
check out our Game Informer and I
believe there's one other publication
and just up talked about that they
played the end game literally just drop
right now a lot Game Informer has a
tweet out about endgame and I believe
one other person I know if all our
places somebody else said they've played
the end game so I'm dying to know what
that's about because at the end of the
day me that's my only concern with Adam
you know once we have the fund the
initial honeymoon phase and we have
having fun with doing stuff does that
end game keep us going and if it's not
then we just wait for them you know the
new content drive you still test me or
whatever or the other games but that's
what I got
yeah I was like it's been and I think
that's it I mean it is a PvE focus
there's not PvP that's gonna have some
people either yeah your name I mean it's
just there
PvP in this game would be really insane
to balance I cannot honestly imagine
yeah like see it I don't even know
because I mean say I've got a seeking
missile but seriously try and put a
seeking missile and hit my interceptor
good luck like so I don't I honestly
don't know how that would go and if it's
not in there ever that's okay
what's up monkey punch oh but just the
the coordination of the teams the
comboing effects that you can do
honestly when I was recording footage
I'm just floating in the air with the
storm and I cast down lightning and I'm
literally saying like on my recording
like yeah and one of the coolest
lightning effects that I've probably
ever seen like and it's just like that's
crazy
it's it looks so good so it's just like
the satisfaction of some of those I was
like I don't know it's like how does a
super feel I can know about feels pretty
good smash explosion yeah some of that
other stuff in the game looks pretty
cool too like the Colossus the ultimate
small nuclear bomb launcher saying there
was so my brother was the Colossus and I
was the interceptor there's only one
problem with that you can't see a damn
thing when you're an interceptor in the
fight and my brother fires an a Colossus
ultimate I can't see anything I'm just
in the middle of a firebomb and it's I
can't see anything
I'm blind I'm just in there I'm like oh
my god what is like when I turned my
effect on for my ultimate it's an
intercept term that's a cool I'm just
like just like going crazy with the
blades and everything I'm in there I'm
just like wailing away and your
Ultimates you go invulnerable like I'm
straight-up invincible doesn't matter
which class you're always invincible and
like the Ranger can clear out so many
ads you've got the storm just drop in
elemental meteors on the ground just
busting up everything and it's the combo
is cool the synergy is cool I can only
imagine some people like I mean I'm you
could run as like for storms and freeze
the entire thing and then nobody could
kill anything but if you run like ice
shards and lightning blast like you get
a four storms just tear some stuff up
like I can see some of that four
interceptors would be harder I think
interceptor is going to be a very
valuable support
class cuz like if you can freeze but
then that interceptor can go rip like a
sniper out of the air cuz I love doing
that like my mother would be like he can
take that physical shield up but that's
nine-person they're pelting them pelting
them but if I can jump up and do like my
devastating strike and literally rip
their shield off and they fall to the
ground and then his finish them up real
quick of melees like that's that
interceptors purpose is that like I'm
gonna be out in the flanks taking care
of the guys you gonna have to worry
about well you guys are like in the mix
the a lot of stuff so that's support for
the interceptors gonna be good to have
but as a solo player it's gonna be a
hard person a solo play I agree but what
you just said right there is where
another big part of the difference that
that combination synergy synergy of
defined roles and there are roles that's
like the word that's the thing that's
the difference would anthem and I said
they got they got the foundation is
there you know is it unless you see
let's see what they continue to cook up
let's see what content they continue to
produce and like I said they've got
they've got something already on the
ground level that I'm enjoying yeah I
mean I'm totally with you on that one
plank I am I'm hooked enough that I know
I'm definitely gonna play the crap out
of this for a little while and then as
you said the longevity it's just like
and what we're about to talk about the
other successor to something else
they're leveling up could be really cool
but if I get to the end and there's not
that next piece or the raid whether it's
like you know grinding for exotic like
even destiny has exotics that's why some
of the times you repeat activities over
and over if I get to a point where I
feel like I'm comfortably mid max if
I've got a fully legendary javelin what
is next and that's gonna be the big
question everybody has what is that in
game what does it feel like and honestly
users won't know until it comes out or
apparently today we'll see but we have
one more thing to talk about because the
world of looter shooters doesn't have
enough to do and sleep not an option if
you like these type of games right now
you're probably just gonna have to pick
for a little while but yeah we got we
got another game that somehow managed to
get in the mix of all this yeah we do
visual and it's called zpv Jean Bradley
for the Europeans over there at Ubisoft
so I know I talked my head off for
anthem so I'm gonna let you take it away
because we got a beta coming up on the
7th yeah but right around it listen man
no rest for the weary destiny I have no
eyeballs anymore I ripped
yeah dude destiny last word quest then
we had Adam this weekend and then boom
the vigils like hey remember me I'm back
baby sad like it's not on the chair he's
like my favorite division - listen man
do not under state what's going on here
okay so first of all private beta
February 7th to the 10th
you don't mean so you got you good
please pre-order you can get you
guaranteed way in or you can hope to try
to get it in yourself but here's the
thing you know they're doing two main
missions available in story normal and
hard mode it's gonna be part of the
content they're gonna have the open
world with five additional side missions
control points and activities all that
good stuff we're getting dark zone in
this well three zones I'm not told you
guys about that how I'm really a fan of
that as far as do we get one of the
three yeah well I believe yeah one of
the three and um you correct up thanks
for correcting me on that you're one of
the three and um you know it's really
cool because like we said before with
the dark zones how they doing it for the
hardcore they're gonna have that
occupied zone the guys that like to come
home yeah that stuff sound lethal like -
coming in over level with the you know
all your stuff and you want to overpower
go at it then for guys like me who don't
want to deal with you Psychopaths I can
go to the other zones which is gonna
have level balancing and gear balancing
so that actually is gonna require my
skill versus the other guy as opposed to
that guy no life the game and he just
got better getting me and I have no shot
at killing it
nothing so I love that balance in the
occupied aspect being rotated so that's
cool I'm excited about that the other
thing they're gonna have the PvP mode
which again never used to really be
there in Division one well they've got
the skirmish I'm very curious to see how
PvP play because this is a dedicated PvP
mode most people either was you were you
were you either in or out on dog so when
you say that like II like some people
really loved it the aspect of it because
of the tension and all that stuff it was
something unique and then other people
like I don't really care for I just want
to play for you
I'll get a dedicated so I thought that's
cool and um yeah man and then the last
thing if you see at the end that nice
touch end game content so this invaded
mission that's a big deal you know this
so I'm dying to know a first look at
endgame content now we got to figure out
is this the raid is this what and I
doubted me the raid but what endgame
content do you think this is what do you
think it says invaded mission I don't
know we know for a fact they have eight
play of rays my gut is telling me this
what they reveal that this in a beta
doubt it so I think it may be something
else
what I'll be like a tougher mission with
more mechanics or maybe like a different
faction that you fight yeah because I
mean if you picture as you level up in
the story I mean you're going through
you gotta you get like the city workers
kind of like the industrial type you
have just a crazy like just kind of
little loony people who were just like
you know scrappy and then you had the
soldiers like you had the basically the
army slash militia as those final people
that you'd fight in Division one and
those guys change the game like that was
a point so I don't know if they consider
like a later mission an in-game or if
they were hollow I don't think they're
gonna show like a full incursion or
whatever that would be called I don't
think that would be what we see yeah he
says he doesn't think is not a raid
incursion I think this is a comparable
to the legendary missions that they have
so yeah I think it may be that ya see
them revealing that hand cuz they
definitely say they play a raid I can't
see them doing that in the private beta
but I like the fact that we getting a
little taste of something and then
obviously the specialization classes
which is on another thing you know
that's supposed to be you know at the
level cap of thirty that you unlock
which is also part of this end game and
this is the thing listen I know the
people who like anthem probably don't
anyone hit hit anthem anthem anthem I
don't care what you talk about right I
get that an anthem is the new sexy high
thing everybody's loving it I feel you
but here's the thing you gotta pay
attention to do
vision has endgame the visit has
multiple modes multiple things for you
to engage in if you don't like the one
aspect and we learned this with death
nesting went through its PvE drought
they had trials trials kept the game a
lot for a long time you know exam mm-hmm
gambit right destiny has rate you got
all these different pockets of the game
that you can enjoy and you can just
invest yourself in just that division to
me is starting to mold themselves that
way they start and Nick say okay you
know what there's people that just won't
do the PvE fine you know and we have to
police here the division police coming
and there we've got oh yeah they're out
the old man the Washington DC's here
alright so there we got the Dark Soul
right for the people that like the
tension you're going they're going to
these zones PvE versus PvP that little
combo a very unique thing right then you
got the dedicated PvP right you got that
you've got the endgame we encourages
they got all these different things so
like I said we talked about this maybe
two last words ago was that you know my
thing with them that I feel that they
got down is that endgame and I I think
in the long game against provided anthem
doesn't you know Fane whatever I am
concerned about anthem long term and I'm
more confident in division long term so
I can't wait I can't wait he's next week
I want to get your feeling you know now
that all this news kind of dropped on
division I know you you're bored leading
anthem I know but what is your feeling
overall when he just read what was gonna
be in is a reactive I mean that's a big
beta but I will honestly say I wish for
all of these that it wasn't just smashed
into one weekend I wish it was pretty
good beat they don't care but have
flexibility for more like I mean the
private beta even if it was like hey if
I'd like pre-ordered the game private
beta I'm out of town for the weekend I'm
screwed like or if I've got stuff going
on that weekend I mean it's not super
all week in which that's what is a
trouble this weekend but again if it
just gave a few more days even it was
like in the Monday and Tuesday and maybe
for them it's like they have to condense
it into a weekend so then they can
back onto a real work week on Monday but
for son just I mean you've got missions
to play you've got side missions to
explore you've got an open world to
explore you've got control points
activities dark zone to go wander around
and play some PvP than an in-game that
launches like the next day I'm like holy
mother like that's a lot of crap to do
mm-hmm
so and that's I forget who said it in
your chat
yeah sundown said it so you you're gonna
go like you've got all spectrums of
mobility in these three games yes
destiny fits somewhere in the middle
because you are still grounded but
you've got space magic jumping and
double jumps and stuff like that
division your boots on the ground can
steal that met but you are literally I
mean it's methodical its tactical its
military it's in their anthem is life
apparently they went up a little early
really I can't even jump into anthem
until him done with my ad I got my serve
video to do I still need to edit my damn
last word quest video - um so you've got
all of these things to do which is
insane sorry about the picture being
crappy but yeah apparently anthem is
life it is life damn it
now I will say like destiny is kept a
cosmetic mm-hmm anthem is kept a
cosmetic there is a pre-order bonus I
know it's not that big of a deal and I
know most things probably aren't like
game breaking but pre-ordering for stash
face bugs me still yeah so that just
doesn't sit right
I don't think they really did enough in
microtransactions to break it before
either so I don't think that's a road
that they would go down but I don't even
know if I'm ever gonna be able to touch
like all of the stuff in this beta it's
nuts yeah it's insane this is a lot of
car I'm actually shocked that they're
giving this much content man I am really
think of how many missions were in
destiny 1 and that doesn't go Division 1
because I mean you had like full-sized
missions not the not SciQuest and stuff
but the full big missions because like
main missions two of them like there was
I don't know maybe 10 or 12 like if you
give me like a fifth or sixth of like
all your main missions that's a that's a
lot to offer it's a lot of and to me
they're coming out like they this is
what the way I look at it they know
they're not stupid they know what's
going on anthem anthems getting a huge
boost and a following for the most part
positive reviews once people have gotten
a chance to play it so they got to keep
the vision fresh in people's mind right
now otherwise it's gonna get forgotten
so I think they had to take this
approach you know saying to kind of say
hey we're here we're coming
you don't mean like don't forget about
us and it's right after all anthem kind
of ends so I think it was the right move
they think they can't play around I
think division knows the stakes because
before division all they had to worry
about was destiny you know so to speak
you know anthem is this wild card right
now so I love it I love it you know you
got three Luna shooters all competing
you know it's really intense right now
and at the end of the day we all benefit
because they have to put their best foot
forward everyone wants a piece of the
pie everybody wants that population base
so this is good stuff man I can't wait I
literally I told you I've been low-key
excited for division so I'm very curious
to see how much has changed and how far
they go with this uh this content yeah I
mean it's one of those that like this is
what I was saying earlier like the level
grind for me for one to 13 division was
awesome like I that had me hooked I was
grinding through and playing through and
then it got to that like in-game wall
and we've said this before if they like
balance that phasing out give you more
legs in the end game different stuff to
do the dark zones they seem to have like
figured out that hey there's to normal
there's the one insanity one like all
the normalizations smaller zone so you
can actually hunt people down like
they've really taken a lot of feedback
and hopefully turn this into I don't
know it could be epic - so I was like I
just don't have enough time to play all
these games right that's what all this
comes down to the end because I know
we're gonna have stuff to do in destiny
still it's a thing absolutely anthem is
gonna be a hell of a min/max grind of
which you can put hours and hours and
like you want to run something over and
over did use the Grandmaster 3
difficulty like oh my god and save 30
100 percent damage
and and health I'm like oh like that
sounds so brutal I know we were just
like level 15 maybe some 19 items
dropping I don't know what at the level
cap is gonna be but my worry is that I'm
gonna get walloped for a little while so
it's good we'll see it's gonna be the
same and I can't wait like this is a
good time it's a good tie like I don't
know how I'm have kind of play all this
stuff well I I won't I don't I'm gonna
be I'm gonna be the content creator that
is like three weeks behind everyone I'll
eventually get there and maybe you guys
will watch them maybe you won't but I'll
do my best to get some stuff out there
between all these things but I'm gonna
be like you're gonna be like oh how's
your desk Division two going it's like
I'm level four how's anthem going I'm
level six how destiny I destiny crap
I haven't logged in this week I'm just
like I'm not I'm gonna have no eyeballs
it's gonna it's it's a really good time
to be a gamer everybody has a niche they
can play if you want to play military
you've got your tactical like some of
the best cover mechanics I've ever felt
and it's gonna be like do you know
really about the you know the guns and
the missions and just really like learn
in that game anthem that's your Ironman
Diablo simulator which is just a lot of
fun it's a blast it's all PvE not
worrying about anything
Destiny's still solid probably in the
best place it's pinned and and outside
of that it's just like take your pick
it's and that's I think one of the
biggest things I've seen out there and a
lot of people have said it too it's not
a point in bashing games right now
there's no point in doing that everybody
has different opinions everybody finds
something fun find what you enjoy and
enjoy it whichever one of these or if
you're playing Kingdom Hearts 3 or
anything else
enjoy your games if you don't enjoy
something that's why there's 20,000
different movies and books and
everything else everybody has a
different variety and just enjoy your
piece of the pie
absolutely Bret well said man I mean
that's literally what it is and you got
enough variety for everything like you
said you want your tactical you got to
tattoo you want your space magic and all
the stuff you want your Iron Man what
you do you've got options man and if one
game what's cool is if one games not
giving you something that you want at
the moment boom you got two other ones
too to dive into so that's the cool part
you know I mean like the downtime part
isn't a big blow now because it's this
competition so it is what it is
and I mean you probably wrapped it up
pretty well there's on top of it it's
like if one thing goes through a lull
now you've got two other things to grind
out on waiting for maybe like that notes
question destiny or eight we're two
weeks away from the first rate and
anthem to be like hey I grinded up
okay well season her if you're just
started let me do that for two weeks and
come back when there it comes
okay Division beat the first raid I'm
kind of hanging out in this spot oh
we've got a new season like it's just
gonna be this constant like chicken with
my head cut off from there I'm just
trying to keep up with these three good
times gaming this is good as good as as
you said their hashtag no life no sleep
and bloodshot eyes that's that's
probably what we're gonna end up with so
we're over two and a half hours I know
I knew we destiny started to go along I
was like oh we have so much to talk
about so we probably rushed through both
of these there will be more to discuss
I'm sure again if how kind of the anthem
demo feels again when I get a little bit
more on classes we'll touch on it again
next week the demo for well what we're
looking at the vision will be next week
and we'll see who wins the Super Bowl
and all of those fun things Lily so you
gotta sleep and crash I gotta try and
get my world going and this is all nuts
so anthem demo it's open to the world
find it on your platform and great if
you've been hating now is the time to
jump in jump in there Maggie this is
another thing most people that work so
if you're at home jump in their service
might be better
well yeah check it out man get out of
fact matter of fact I Loki dis tested it
just to see if I can get it while we
were talking and I got it so nice I got
too much on screen again Touch it I
break it right now do scream otters baby
learn from you yeah I think we'll wrap
it up I mean mine short and sweet its
Ubuntu severy we're twitch Twitter and
YouTube follow subscribe any and all
that stuff so you guys know I'll try and
get content out but I'm also trying to
actually live a human life and play
these games too so I will try and get
all those things balanced but you guys
know where to find me it's Yvonne chess
I'm the only one so if anybody's trying
to take that name good luck but yeah I
think I'm just the only abundance out
there so search it you'll find me scream
what's going on bro yo yeah and of
course you
domi at lord Cognito of the iron Lords
podcast so please check us out should be
a big special guest this Sunday we
should have the CEO and Game Director of
ashen so Derrick Bradley will be in the
building come check us out of your fan
of souls games Dark Souls type games
stuff like that we're gonna deep dive
with them talk some gaming or that game
I need to look at it again I know what
you're talking about I feel like I've
looked at me like that looks cool store
as well if you're gonna do it on PC so
yeah cooperative Dark Souls really cool
art style you know really got some
really good reviews very strong started
off initially as a xbox exclusive you
know it's actually in-game pass as well
so if you have game packs you can just
get it get it there if you don't want to
plunk down the dough but um yeah man
he's gonna be joining the realm it's
gonna be a special time normally due
Sunday at 1:00 because he's in New
Zealand it'll be uh at 3:00 because we
don't want him waking up crazy early so
I just check this out 3:00 p.m. Eastern
Standard Time on the Isle of podcast
channel and then right after that go
watch the Super Bowl enjoy yourself man
that's what I got and yeah it shout out
to the graphic god man put that image up
what Motel are we going back here we go
let's wrap it up where we started you
guys haven't seen or you tune in later
this is our new logo so this will be
everywhere gonna look at on getting the
audio versions up and this is gonna be
slapped on that so yeah shout out thank
you again graphic god for make it look
so good and you just encapsulated what
we're going for you crushed it
absolutely sort of fireside chats this
is how we get down talking about these
Louis shooters really exchanging
thoughts that his scream is like oh we
bad you that man enough but we got the
vision man both represents us I will say
I know you work out but damn those arms
man calm down sir not come to Guardian
con is not an accurate representation of
me yeah that's yeah I know you'll live
up to the ninja closer than I live up to
the cheetah self oh she did it all
metaphor not physical
but yeah you guys are all awesome thank
you both chats were amazing today so
stay tuned I'll be streaming a lot this
weekend so come over check my stream
twitch.tv slash Yvonne says I'll be
streaming or let's see what I have to
try to do this weekend play imp them
probably classes that didn't focus that
much on see if I can get those maxed out
and have all their abilities and then
shadow throne flawless work on my rare
bounty and Super Bowl party and work in
the morning so I will be doing things
constantly and all the time just do me a
favor while I sleep please let me know
if skull of dong Cara is the advisor you
could wake me else not going no no you
can sleep you'll see them when you wake
up just you need to crash you've been up
for a long time so you sleep it'll be
there when you get up just sleep till
like tomorrow it's crashing that's it
I'm done
ninjas going back cheetahs gonna start
running a million miles an hour because
that's all I can try and do to keep up
with this you guys are amazing and I
will see you all soon
we out you know peace